Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 53. 53. Wir dachten uns, wir machen mal wieder eine so allgemeine Folge, nachdem die letzte ja doch ein bisschen sehr speziell war.
Ja, wir haben eigentlich kein spezielles Thema gehabt und sind jetzt so ein bisschen inspiriert davon, dass gestern die Alarme losging.
Genau, gestern war in Berlin...
Klackson, so die Mobiltelefone meinten plötzlich so...
Genau, du hast ja gerade eine kulturelle Gesamterfahrung, die...
Ich wohnte da im Einzugsgebiet von einer Giftwolke, die über West-Berlin zog und ich habe mir dann bei der Gelegenheit gedacht, dass er nämlich an Fallout, ja weil Fallout ist so eine Videospielserie, die gerade verfilmt wurde bei Amazon und die spielt in einem Paralleluniversum, was eigentlich immer eine satirische Überspitzung war und natürlich Videospiel und so weiter mit der Realität nicht viel zu tun hatte. Aber so in letzter Zeit beobachte ich doch so ein paar Parallelen, die mich ein bisschen unruhig machen. Also bei Fallout geht es um eine Zukunft in 200 Jahren, nachdem in einem subamerikanischen Techno-Optimismus irgendwie aus den 60er Jahren so mit Atomzeitalter alles wird super. Irgendwie ein Atomkrieg, die Welt dezimiert hat, gab es lauter Walls, so Untergrundbunker. Und die Überlebenden aus den Walls kommen jetzt langsam raus, wenn es welche gab, denn nicht alle Walls haben überlebt natürlich. Und die Spiele sind halt immer aus der Perspektive von einem, der gerade aus dem Vault rauskriegt und der sozusagen erlebt, wie die Welt jetzt aussieht. Und die Welt hat halt irgendwie Radioaktivität natürlich und irgendwie mutierte Tiere und alles mögliche. Aber es hat halt auch so ein paar andere Sachen. Die erste Sache war, es gibt kein Geld mehr, weil das waren halt so Papierschnipsel. Die findet man gelegentlich noch, aber die haben keinen Wert mehr. Stattdessen handelt man jetzt mit Bottle Caps. Also das sind so die Kronkorken. Die Kronkorken von Sodaflaschen. Deswegen hab ich hier auch extra meine mitgebracht. Und das haben wir jetzt zwar nicht, aber wenn man mal so im Berliner Straßenbild sich umguckt, dann sieht man ganz viele Leute, die irgendwie mit Flaschen rumpeln, die sie eingesammelt haben. Das heißt, auf eine gewisse Art, finde ich, haben wir schon. So Bargeld wird auch immer weniger wichtig, wird abgeschafft.
Ich glaube, das ist ein nicht einheitlicher Trend. Also wenn ich mich so umgucke, also nicht in Berlin, sondern auch in anderen Städten, gibt es so zwei Sorten Restaurants. Die einen sagen Cash Only.
Und die anderen sagen kein Cash.
Und die anderen sagen irgendwie Card Only. Und dann gibt es noch so die dazwischen, die sagen Karte erst ab 10 Euro oder sowas. Und diese verfolgen grundsätzlich unterschiedliche Philosophien zu diesem Thema. Die einen sagen halt offensichtlich, okay, wir nehmen nur Cash, weil wir keine Lust darauf haben, dass irgendwie jede Transaktion komplett registriert ist und wir irgendwie unseren Schwarzgeld Flexibilisierungspuffer brauchen, um irgendwie diesen Laden ökonomisch zu betreiben. Und die anderen sagen, wir wollen die Cash Handling Kosten nicht haben. Also die Kosten, die man hat, wenn man Bargeld zählen und sich mit dem Bargelschwund durch das Personal auseinandersetzen muss und den Werttransport und so weiter. Und ganz interessant, ich bin noch nicht so sicher, welche Fraktion am Ende gewinnt. Also über sonst gewinnt ja die Kartenfraktionen. Aber ich glaube, in Deutschland ist das noch nicht ausgemacht.
Also auf der einen Seite wirkt Deutschland zumindest, also besonders bei mir, weil ich hab die halt alle in meiner Mailbox. Wenn ich mal wieder über Bargeld rede, dann kommen die ganzen Bargeld, wird abgeschafft, irgendwie Weltregierungsleute in meine Mailbox. Aber ich beobachte halt auf der anderen Seite, dass die Kartenzahlung inzwischen so weit optimiert ist, dass es halt wirklich auch schneller ist, als wenn die Leute da ihr Portemonnaie rausholen. Also inzwischen an der Supermarktkasse.
Die Touchless?
Genau. An der Supermarktkasse inzwischen. Wenn da jemand irgendwie in seine in seine Hosentasche greift und irgendwie die Geldscheine rausholt, so dann wird die Kasse, die Schlange hinter ihm unruhig. So weil, oh nee, weißt du, so und dann so, ja, ich muss jetzt hier gucken, ob ich noch Münzen hab, die passen, weißt du, so und dann. Nee, das war aber die falsche Münze. Das sind dann meistens vielleicht noch ältere Leute, die irgendwie das nicht mehr so genau sehen können. Und dann so geht es hin und her. Also die Toleranz dafür, dass vor dir in der Schlange jemand mit Bargeld zahlt, glaube ich, beobachten zu können, sinkt.
Also es gibt ja noch dieses andere Phänomen, das nämlich dadurch, dass die Banken ja ihre Filialen zumachen und die Geldautomaten ja inzwischen nur noch von irgendwie so Abzockern betrieben werden, die 5 Euro pro Transaktion nehmen, nehmen ja viele Leute ihr Bargeld inzwischen im Supermarkt mit.
Ja, es gibt auch gar keine Möglichkeiten mehr. Also ich habe bei mir neulich mal geguckt, wo eigentlich die nächste Bankfiliale ist. Ich war umzingelt von Banken früher. Da gab es mindestens 8 oder 10 oder so direkt in 200 Meter, 150 Meter Laufabstand.
Du wohnst ja auch in so einer Gegend, wo man halt irgendwie viel Bargeld brauchte.
Naja also. Den Subtext. Ne, aber also inzwischen ist da gar keine mehr. Die sind alle weg. Sogar die Sparkasse und die Volksbanken haben ihre Filialen dezimiert. Da ist einfach nichts mehr. So das heißt, du kannst auch eigentlich nur noch, nicht nur kannst du eigentlich nur noch einen Supermarkt abheben, wenn du bei deiner Bank irgendwie die Geldautomaten oder Abhebsuche benutzt. Da zeigen sie dir inzwischen die Supermärkte an, als seien das Bankfilialen. Das heißt, das ist einfach auch, hat es einfach abgelöst. Also das mit den Supermärkten, das ist inzwischen so der One-Stop-Shop, wie man so schön sagt. Da holst du dein Bargeld und da gibst du es ab. Und ich kann...
Ein Bargeld-Einzahlung ist tatsächlich inzwischen auch so, dass die meisten Banken haben ja keine Bargeld-Schalter mehr, sondern nur noch so Einzahlungsautomaten. Und auch die werden immer weniger, weil die Filialen zu machen. Und dann hast du halt so diese ganzen Neobanken, die halt irgendwie ja so quasi...
Die noch nie eine Filiale hatten?
Die noch nie eine Filiale hatten. Und auch die machen ja Bargeld-Einzahlung in allen möglichen Super- und Drogeriemärkten und so.
Das hab ich noch nicht gut gesehen. Und wie geht das? Da gehst du dann hin mit deinem Geldberg oder wie?
Genau, also du gehst halt irgendwie möglichst irgendwie abends kurz vor Schluss, irgendwie zu... Du gehst halt mit deinem Bargeldberg dahin. Du sagst in deiner App, okay, ich möchte ja gerne Bargeld einzahlen. Und dann zeigt die dir so ein Barcode an, den hältst du irgendwie auf dem Telefon. Der wird dann in der Kasse gescannt. Dann wird in der Kasse ein Einzahlungsvorgang getriggert. Und dann hat die Person an der Kasse dann den großen Spaß, dein Bargeld mindestens dreimal zu zählen. Hoffe ich noch, die Friarlettung dazu zu rufen, wenn man ein bisschen mehr einzahlen möchte. Ich hab das mal vor mir gesehen. Also die hatten wirklich Schiss, dass sie sich erzählen. So war ich keine Ahnung, was sie da eingezahlt hat, aber irgendwie ein bisschen mehr offenbar.
Wer nutzt sowas? So Restaurateur oder Restaurantbetreiber?
Nee, also was ich nachvollziehen konnte, ist gecapped bei 99 Euro oder so pro Tag oder so, oder pro Woche. Nee, es schien eher so, keine Ahnung, Handwerker Schwarzlohn oder sowas. Also keine Ahnung. Also es fällt so ein paar Hundert Euro halt so, nicht 10.000 Euro so.
Ja, aber so das Gesamte, die gesamte Infrastruktur ist einfach weggebrochen. Ich bin so ein bisschen ungehalten darüber, weil gerade so Döner und China-Imbiss und so sind eigentlich komplett noch nur Bargeld in meiner Gegend. Das heißt, wenn du einen Döner haben willst und sagen wir mal irgendwie, du hast jetzt eine Familie, wo dann mehr als eine Person ist, dann gehst du so pro Woche durch irgendwie 200 Euro durch, einfach nur so, dass du halt Bargeld brauchst, um mal zum Imbiss zu holen. Um mal zum Imbiss zu laufen. Ja und das ist halt echt scheiße. Ja und auf der anderen Seite, was mich halt richtig ärgert, wenn ich dann beim Imbiss stehe und sehe, dass sie da so ein iPad von Lieferando haben, wo ich mir denke, also das heißt, ihr nehmt also doch irgendwie nicht Bargeld an, aber halt nicht von mir, sondern nur wenn ich irgendwie über Lieferando komme, dann nehmt ihr auch nicht Bar an, oder wie. Da denk ich mir dann so, boah ey. Aber ich mein, ich ärgere mich halt, weil das alles irgendwie ungerecht aussieht, aber auf der anderen Seite war das ja schon immer alles beschiss. Also ich hab neulich irgendwie, hab ich erst gelernt, weißt du, dass sie im Supermarkt immer so irgendwie 1,90 Euro als Preis haben? Ich dachte immer, das ist wegen der Psychologie, damit die Leute irgendwie glauben, das ist aber unter zwei Euro. Aber es stellt sich raus, das ist eigentlich, damit du an der Kasse die Kasse aufmachen musst, als Kassenbediener, du musst die Kasse aufmachen, um das Restgeld drauf zu geben. Und das heißt, du kannst dir den Schein nicht einfach einstecken. So dafür ist das eigentlich gewesen damals, habe ich neulich gelesen. Und ich dachte mir so, ah, irgendwie leuchtet ein. Glaube ich. Und eigentlich ist die Welt schon immer voll beschiss gewesen um uns rum. Wir haben es nur nicht so gemerkt. Und jetzt mit den Kartengeschichten. Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, das vergleichen einfach die Kartengeschichten mit einer Welt minus den Beschiss, weil der nicht uns betraf, sondern ich glaube es anders tatsächlich so, dass die das ist schon tatsächlich Endgame Kapitalismus, was wir jetzt gerade sehen.
Das heißt, dass immer mehr Businesses in ihrem Optimierungswahn an soweit ans Ende gegangen sind, dass es jetzt anfängt unangenehm zu werden und dass die die Dinge, die sie tun müssen, um noch die letzten ein oder zwei Prozent rauszuquetschen, jetzt halt anfangen, sowohl für ihre Angestellten als auch für ihre Kunden halt irgendwie richtig lästig zu werden. Und daraus resultiert, weil es alle machen, ich hab da irgendwie mal einen Kolumnenbeitrag drüber geschrieben, das Problem, glaube ich, ist einfach, dass alle machen das. Das ist normal geworden und deswegen hast du auch die Auswahl nicht mehr. Du hast nicht mehr die Auswahl, zu irgendjemandem zu gehen, der dich nicht bescheißt.
Die ist halt worden, das Ding gibt es nicht mehr.
Gibt es nicht mehr. Also es gibt alles, es ist halt alles, es ist halt nur noch ein Scam, bzw. halt irgendwie fast ein Scam geworden. Und dann hast du halt irgendwie die Auswahl nur noch, wenn du wirklich reich bist und halt für den Service bezahlst.
Was meine Perspektive da ja deutlich geändert hat, war, als ich mal mitgekriegt hab, so der CCC macht ja immer Kongress und Camp. Und ich hab dann mal so Überbande mitgekriegt, was das für ein Aufwand ist, wenn du als Veranstalter von so einem Camp irgendwie, da sag ich mal, einen Essensstand haben willst und der will Bargeld annehmen und der muss dann halt Bargeld vorhalten. Wie viel Kohle du einfach im Vorfeld schon irgendwie organisieren musst, damit die wechseln können und was du da für einen für einen Stress am Bein hast, wenn du das dann abends irgendwo einzahlen willst und so. Also ich kann das schon wirklich verstehen, wenn irgendein Laden dann sagt, ne, wir nehmen nur Karte. Den Scheiß wollen wir nicht haben. Das kann ich wirklich verstehen, nachdem ich irgendwie da so ein paar Schilderungen gehört hab. Und ich denk mir, also ich hab noch nie irgendwie so einen Einzelhandel betrieben. Deswegen kann ich da nur irgendwie spekulieren. Aber so mein Verständnis ist, dass sie das Geld dann in so einer Kassette irgendwie wohintragen. Oder es kommt irgendwie ein Panzerwagen, wenn es ein größerer Betrieb ist.
Ja, es hängt halt sehr davon ab, wie groß die Umsätze sind. Aber ja, Bargeld handling ist halt jetzt schon nicht kostenlos. Auf der anderen Seite erlaubt es gerade in der Gastro Bargeld oder auch in Spätis und so, den Leuten halt einfach ein Teil irgendwie in der Steuer vorbei abzuzweigen. Und dadurch halt einfach mindestens die Mehrwertsteuer und halt irgendwie die, was auch immer sie auf ihren Gewinn an Steuern zahlen würden, irgendwie zu sparen und dadurch halt irgendwie auch die Preise noch einigermaßen bezahlbar halten zu können.
Aber es gibt da ganz viele Theorien. Also ich hab das mit dem, diese Theorie hab ich ganz viel über Restaurants gehört. Und dann haben wir aber ein paar so Restaurantbetreiber geschrieben, dass es da relativ strikte Regeln gibt inzwischen für den Umgang mit. Ja, also das heißt, du kannst immer noch bescheißen, aber du musst ja mehr Mühe geben. Du musst ja mehr Mühe geben und du musst irgendwie heucheln in einer kleineren, irgendwie entbürokratisierten Umsatzkategorie zu sein. Also ab einer gewissen Größe geht das auch mit, wir geben uns Mühe nur noch sehr schwer bzw. kaum noch.
Aber du siehst es dann halt eben auch. Günstige Preise für Essen kriegst du halt nur noch in sehr kleinen Läden und sobald die halt innerhalb einer bestimmten Größe sind, sind die dann halt auch richtig teuer. Also man hat den Effekt, hat man halt in Amsterdam zum Beispiel sehr deutlich gesehen, als sie da halt irgendwie quasi Bargeld im Wesentlichen abgeschafft haben und irgendwie die Kartenzahlung dann direkt in deren digital signierende Registrierkassen ging und so weiter. Und dann gingen sofort die Restaurantpreise um mindestens ein Viertel hoch. Ja. Es ist halt so, klar kann man sagen, okay, die sollen doch alle ordentlich ihre Steuern zahlen und so. Auf der anderen Seite, ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich mir so Cum-Ex angucke, dann irgendwie muss ich sagen, irgendwie ist der Vietnameser an der Ecke, der mir halt irgendwie meine Asianudeln für 2 Euro Bläger verkaufen kann, weil er mir Bar verkauft. Das finde ich jetzt irgendwie dann im Vergleich doch sehr legitim so.
Also wir haben so einen China-Imbiss, zu dem ich immer ganz gerne hingegangen bin. Und die hatten dann auf der Markise stehen vor dem Ladengeschäft Telefonnummer. Und dann konnte sie anrufen. Und dann haben die dir das auch gebracht. Und die Markise ist immer noch da, weil den Dienst gibt es nicht mehr, weil der ist komplett einfach übernommen worden von Uber Eats und Lieferanten und was es da gibt. Das fand ich auch hart, ja, weil...
Die nehmen richtig viel Prozent.
Die nehmen richtig Aufschlag. Also nicht nur das. Die haben ja eigene Webseiten, die so tun, als seien sie das Geschäft. Sind es aber nicht. Das finde ich auch, kommt dazu. Was eigentlich auch an Betrug grenzt, finde ich.
Ja, das ist Scam.
Stehen dann halt Preise, die nicht die des Restaurants sind, sondern das ist halt plus Aufschlag für Lieferung. Damit sie sagen können, die Lieferung kostet nichts. Lügen sie dir halt bei den Preisen ins Gesicht.
Also hier im Wedding Zone, wir sitzen ja gerade in der Romford Agentur an Rekorden. Und hier ist halt so, dass viele von den Restaurants, die hier liefern, bringen dir bei der Lieferung immer, also die liefern noch selber. Also ist dann so ein Dude, der halt für zwei der Restaurants die Lieferung macht. Und der bringt dir immer einen Flyer mit und sagt dir, pass auf, order mal lieber hier direkt, ist billiger. Also zu sagen, dass das Mittelmeer Pricing wird jetzt halt explizit. Das heißt also, was früher halt quasi dieses implizite Ding war, von wegen so, ja, ja, nimm mal Uber Eats oder Lieferanten oder whatnot. Oder Deliveroo und dann für billig Essen ordern, kehrt sich jetzt halt um, weil die einen so großen Teil des Volumens ausmachen, auch für die Restaurants, dass die, naja, die nehmen halt ein zweistellige Prozent, setzt du halt irgendwie von den Restaurants?
Und so 50 Prozent. Also wir reden von richtig krassen Ausschlägen bei Lieferanten und so. Also das ist 50 Prozent. Es kommt natürlich darauf an, wo man ordert. Aber also die Ausschläge sind richtig, richtig. Ich war neulich in so einem Restaurant, bin ich dann hingegangen, weil ich mir dachte, wenn ich irgendwie bei Lieferanten oder so bestelle, dann landet die Kohle ja bei Lieferanten. Und das Essen schmeckt mir. Also möchte ich eigentlich, dass das Restaurant bezahlt wird und gehe dann halt hin. Wenn es irgendwie nicht weit weg ist. Und dann gehe ich also zu dem Restaurant hin und stelle fest, die haben einen Tisch, in dem man sitzen kann. Und ansonsten war das offensichtlich mal ein Restaurant, aber da sind jetzt zwei Restaurants drin. Ja, links irgendwie so ein Italiener, also nur Küche und rechts so ein Asier, irgendwie auch nur Küche. Und der gesamte Umsatz kommt von Lieferanten. Genau, also gibt's das heißt, du kannst dich da, es gibt noch einen Tisch, damit sie sagen können, sie sind ein Laden-Restaurant, aus irgendwie steuerlichen Gründen haben, nehme ich an. Aber der gesamte Umsatz sind Leute, die entweder abholen oder sich liefern lassen. Das ist ja wow.
Also gibt es auch als komplettes Start-up-Model, das heißt Ghost Kitchen. Das ist also wirklich, es funktioniert wirklich so, also mit jeder Menge Scams, die da dran hängen. Also es funktioniert halt so, dass die Küchen einrichten, möglichst in halbwegs günstigen Gewerbeimmobilien. Und die Location davon spufen, damit, und da sind es dann halt häufig so, keine Ahnung, so fünf, sechs Restaurants, also Fake-Restaurants drin, also die halt irgendwie, also quasi so, was normalerweise früher immer der IMS war, der dann so Asiadöner, Italo, Sushi und Burger irgendwie hatte, haben die dann da wirklich alle, alles in einem und haben halt irgendwie dadurch ein bisschen, also ein bisschen Synergien, weil halt zentraler Einkauf und so weiter.
Wie, aber die tun so, als wären sie in deiner Nähe, aber liefern dann halt, oder wie?
Genau.
Ist ja hart.
Und die sind halt, weil viele Leute sortieren halt natürlich nach irgendwie, was ist denn bei der Nähe, ne? Um die Lieferzeit zu senken und was die halt machen, ist, dass die dann halt sich, die entweder direkt GPS die Position patchen in ihrem iPad, auf dem die Lieferungen ankommen, oder, habe ich auch schon gesehen, sich tatsächlich ein Screen Forward machen. Das heißt, die haben wirklich dann irgendwo in irgendeiner Wohnung oder so, in, keine Ahnung, in einer teuren Gegend in der Mitte oder so. Oder in Prenzlauer Berg haben die dann halt eine Wohnung, wo dann so zehn so iPads sind, die dann screen forwarded werden, damit sie halt irgendwie in den Kitchens landen. Und dann sieht es halt so aus, als wäre das Restaurant halt am Helmholtzplatz, aber de facto ist es halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, in Lichtenberg oder so, ne?
Ja, also ich fand interessant, ich weiß nicht, ob du mal zur Anschrift von so einem Pizza-Lieferdienst gegangen bist, irgendwie so. Bei mir um die Ecke gibt's ein Ladengeschäft von Pizza Max. Es gibt also jetzt auch andere, oder Cole Pizza hat auch Ladendokale, kannst du hingehen, oder Domino's oder so.
Ja, Domino's hab ich mal gesehen, ja.
Und die haben halt eine Anschrift für ihren Laden, das weiß man ja auch, weil man sagt ja, wo man hingeliefert haben will, und dann sagen sie, der Laden ist am nächsten. Und normalerweise gehst du da aber nicht hin, weil die ja liefern. Aber ich bin da halt mal vorbeigekommen und hab das dann mal angeguckt. Und es ist halt auch so was, ja, das sah eigentlich aus wie diese Ghost Kitchen, ja. Also das ist ein echter Laden, da kannst du rein gehen, so mit Tür und Beschriftung und allem.
Es gibt nur eine Theke.
Aber es gibt nur eine Theke. Und da kannst du halt auch sagen, ich hätte gern so und so und möchte das mitnehmen, aber eigentlich ist es eine Küche. So, Punkt.
Ja.
Und lustigerweise, bei diesem einen Pizza-Ding stand dann so ein Oktoberfest-Holztisch davor, womit wir so full circle werden bei dieser anderen Küche. Die so theoretisch, also es gibt nicht nur die Küche, die so tut als eisende Küche, sondern es gibt auch den Lieferdienst, der sagt, also du willst ganz natürlich auch hinsetzen.
Also bei der Enfiliale da in Mitte um die Ecke, die haben auch so irgendwie da so einen Tisch davor stehen im Sommer, aber primär hängen halt die Lieferfahrer dann rum.
Ja, also die verkaufen ja auch irgendwie Getränke und Eis oder so. Ich kann mir also vorstellen, dass ich das nicht an Leute richtet, die essen wollen, sondern die einfach mal irgendwie eine Erfrischung brauchen oder so. Na ja, gut, aber die Themen, die mich an Fallout erinnern, sind ja nicht nur irgendwie, dass wir hier Atomruinen haben, die dann halt nicht von einer Bombe sind, sondern ein Atomkraftwerk, was wir abgeschaltet haben. Wir sind ja jetzt auch eigentlich im postnuklearen Ruinenzeitalter hier. Und ich habe ja immer noch Diskussionen am Lauf mit irgendwelchen Leuten, die finden, das sei ungerecht. Wer zieht so, hat gerade so einen angeblichen Skandal aufgedeckt bezüglich der Atomabschaltung. Man hätte die ja noch weiter laufen können. Das war irgendwie die Behauptung, dass innerhalb des Ministeriums sei irgendwie die Meinung unterdrückt worden.
Aber die hatten das Dokument nicht zu Ende gelesen, ne?
Also ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, weil man weiß ja auch nicht, wie viel die da tatsächlich veröffentlicht haben. Also wenn es die wohlwollende Darstellung ist, die wohlwollende Darstellung ist, die haben irgendwie nur die Hälfte gelesen. Und dann gab es aber natürlich die andere Darstellung, die haben doch recht gehabt und ehrlich gesagt ist mir das scheißegal. Die sind jetzt ausgeschaltet und die Presse von damals hat mir völlig gereicht. Da stand halt drin irgendwie, die Kraftwerke waren im Wesentlichen am Ende. Es gab auch im Wochen-Tonus irgendwelche, dieses Kraftwerk ist jetzt abgeschaltet worden, weil es halt eigentlich durch. Aber es gibt halt noch so zwei Wochen auf der Lebenszeit. Und die Regulierungsbehörde hat dann halt in den letzten Wochen nicht mehr so genau hingeguckt. Sondern wenn da irgendwas mit Klebeband kurzfristig fixbar war, haben die halt nicht darauf bestanden, dass das neue Erdbund abgenommen wird. Sondern das war schon alles voll am Ende. Und insbesondere das Personal war am Ende.
Ich hab da mal so eine Doku, so eine längere Doku drüber gesehen, über so irgendeins der Kraftwerke, was dann am Ende abgeschaltet wurde. Und da war halt auch schon sehr klar, dass die langfristige Planung spielt bei so einem Atomkraftwerk halt eine riesengroße Rolle. Und du kannst die halt weder schnell an, noch schnell abschalten. Also jetzt so wieder in Betrieb nehmen oder so. Weil halt alles irgendwie unglaublich reguliert ist. Und irgendwie, die Leute müssen ausgebildet sein und zertifiziert sein. Und die Anlagenfahrer und die ganze Material muss irgendwie sehr alles irgendwie, also Material, was in eine kerntechnische Anlage geht, ist der deutsche Bürokratiebegriff, muss auch alles irgendwie den diversesten Anforderungen und Tests irgendwie genügen und alle N-Jahre nochmal neu getestet werden und so. Und die Schweißnähte müssen getestet werden und Druckprüfungen und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie weißt, okay, das wird jetzt eh in N-Jahren abgeschaltet, dann lässt du die halt bis ans Ende von diesem Prüfzyklus laufen. Natürlich tust du das, weil so eine Prüfung kostet einen höhen Geld. Ja, klar. Aber wenn die dann halt einmal, es gibt dann so dieses Überlappende, also wenn die jährlich geprüft werden, dann ist alles gut. Aber wenn du dann halt sagst, okay, wir maxen jetzt mal die Periode aus, wie lange so eine Prüfung hält, die dann irgendwie drei Jahre ist oder sowas, dann musst du danach quasi so eine Neuzulassungsprüfung machen. So musst du halt irgendwie einmal komplett alles als neue kerntechnische Anlage zulassen. Und das Zeug aus den 70s, was da teilweise gelaufen ist, kriegst du gar nicht mehr zugelassen. Also hast du keine Chance.
Naja, aber das sind jetzt so die physischen Gründe. Aber was gerne übersehen wird, es gab seit 30 Jahren keinen Nachwuchs, weil das einfach keiner studiert hat. Weil klar war, irgendwie das Zeitalter ist zu Ende. Und das heißt, die Leute, die da gearbeitet haben, waren alle im Wesentlichen schon in Rente und man hat ihnen halt ein paar mehr Euro gezahlt, damit sie noch ein Jahr da bleiben. So, das heißt, als dann Schluss war, war halt wirklich Schluss. Die Leute gibt es einfach nicht mehr, die das betreiben können. Die sind in Rente.
Oder machen halt lieber Fusionsforschungen. Also wenn jetzt halt irgendwie...
Ja, ja gut, aber das sind jetzt nicht so viele. Oder? Weiß ich nicht.
Naja, ich meine, als wir im Greifswald waren, war ja so eine kerntechnische Anlage. Und das heißt also, die Leute, die da arbeiten, müssen halt eben zumindest zum Teil eben auch die entsprechenden Ausbildungen, bzw. Studiengänge haben, um halt irgendwie jetzt irgendwie zu fliegen zu können.
Aber ich hab jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass da die ganzen irgendwie schon fast vor den fast beruheständeten irgendwie alten Leute rumrennen.
Ich meine nur die paar Leute, die halt noch irgendwie Kerntechnik, also Anlagentechnik irgendwie mit Spezifikation Kerntechnik studieren, die gehen halt eher nach Greifswald als in so einer Atomruine, wo sie halt den alten Kram abreißen können.
Ich finde, das etablieren wir jetzt mal. Atomruine ist jetzt der Begriff für die Angratwerke. Ja, ansonsten finde ich gerade auffällig, dass wir im Moment so im Monatsabstand irgendwelche neuen irgendwie Halsmeldungen aus der Fusionsforschung kriegen, dass irgendjemand irgendeinen Durchbruch verkündet. Die werden jetzt nicht alle irgendwie der tolle Durchbruch sein, aber so dieses Gefühl, dass wir uns nach vorne bewegen, habe ich gerade bei der Fusion deutlich mehr. Da geht auch richtig Geld ran. Nicht nur wir verbrennen jetzt Kohle, sondern da kommen dann auch Meldungen, die klingen, als wenn es wirklich irgendwo nach vorne gegangen wäre.
Was ich ganz interessant finde, wenn ich mit Leuten darüber rede, dass wir da in Kassel waren und so angeguckt haben und so. Und dass es mit der Fusion ja dann vielleicht langsam doch irgendwie was werden könnte, ist so dieser fast maßerfüllte negativ Blick da drauf. So dieses irgendwie so, ja, das wird sowieso nichts. Und wenn es was wird, dann wird es viel teurer als Solar. Und ja, sagen die ja selber, ich meine, haben die uns ja selber gesagt, so das wird halt nie so billig sein wie Solar. Also war halt klar, wie aber.
Ist ja auch nicht als Konkurrenz gedacht, sondern für den Fall, wo die Sonne halt gerade nicht scheint.
Wo die Sonne nicht scheint und der Wind nicht weht. Und das halt irgendwie, glaube ich, und oder auf dem Mars oder auf dem Mond oder wo auch immer. Und oder an Atom-Urboten oder an Flugzeugträgern oder sonst wo man es gerade wichtig findet. Und ich hab irgendwie so ein bisschen so und die Begründung, die dann immer kommt, ist dann so, ja, wenn man jetzt irgendwie so eine Technologie irgendwie gut findet, so dann ist man ja also zum einen schon entweder fast FDP-Wähler, weil man ja irgendwas tut, was denn dazu führt, dass irgendjemand der Meinung sein könnte, so verzichtsbasierter CO2-Reduktion wäre jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr so, dass der der Megatrend.
Nee, noch schlimmer, du bist ein Tech-Bro, weil du an die Technik...
Genau, ich bin ein Tech-Bro, weil ich halt irgendwie die Technologie jetzt irgendwie nicht so durchfinde. Und mich nervt das gerade zusehends, weil halt irgendwie so, dass man da nicht differenziert darüber reden kann, und sagen kann, ok, pass auf, wir werden jedes Stück Technologie brauchen, was wir kriegen können, wenn wir uns irgendwie aus dieser Situation irgendwie rauswinden wollen als Menschheit. Dass die Leute das immer noch nicht verstanden haben. Ich finde das wirklich frustrierend, so dass sie halt wirklich diese ideologische Sicht auf irgendwie Klimaschutz, die sagt, man darf auf gar keinen Fall irgendetwas diskutieren oder gar finanzieren, was jetzt nicht nur verzichtspasierte CO2-Minderungen ist, die findet langsam nicht mehr, nicht mehr erträglich so.
Mich ärgert auch dieses Oszillieren, würde ich fast sagen. Wir oszillieren immer zwischen der Klimawandel, wir müssen jetzt was tun und dann aber die Wirtschaft ist nicht so viel gewachsen, wir müssen jetzt was tun. So dass es dasselbe ist. Die Wirtschaft kann nicht ewig wachsen. Das ist irgendwie noch nicht angekommen.
Es sei denn, man hat Technologie, die es möglich macht, dass man sehr viel energieeffizienter arbeitet. Dafür braucht man aber halt Technologie und dafür muss man Technologie investieren.
Das ist ja nicht nur die Energie, die da irgendwie mit der wir Raubbau betreiben. Nicht nur die Energie, sondern auch irgendwie.
Rohstoffe, Wasser.
Wobei auch da gibt es Fortschritte, mit denen ich so nicht gerechnet habe und was freut mich gerade sehr. Also gerade heute gab es die Meldung, dass jetzt die EU mal in Natriumbatterien investieren möchte. Was andere Orts schon längst in Produktion ist, machen wir jetzt auch. Und da, das wäre gut, weil die Lithiumvorräte ungleichmäßig verteilt sind.
Nein, nicht nur sind sie ungleichmäßig verteilt, sondern die Förderung ist auch echt nicht so umweltschonend. Das ist bei Natrium halt irgendwie einfacher. Und die sind halt auch sehr viel billiger. Deswegen, weil Natrium halt irgendwie ein sehr viel häufigeres Material in der Erdoberfläche ist.
Und die halten nicht so lange, aber müssten sie auch nicht. Brauchst halt dann doppelt so viele Akkus.
Na, was heißt halt nicht so lange? Die haben nicht so eine hohe Kapazität, aber die...
War nicht die Ladezyklen auch ein Problem?
Ich glaube, die Anzahl Ladezyklen war kein Problem. Okay, na gut.
Ja, aber gut. Also es ist ja dasselbe in Grün. Brauchst halt mehr Batterien für dieselben...
Genau, also du hast halt eine geringere Discharge Rate. Das heißt, du kannst halt weniger viel Strom rausziehen. Deswegen halt bei den chinesischen Autos, die die gerade verbauen. Das hat immer so Mischbetrieb. Da hast du halt ein Lithium-Akku, der wird halt benutzt, wenn du halt gerade mal beschleunigst. Und ein Natrium-Akku, der halt quasi zum Cruisen so verwendet wird. Und was ja auch vollkommen okay ist. Also man kann ja Technologiekomplexität auch mal verwenden, irgendwie für sinnvolle Sachen. Aber um nochmal kurz auf dieses Technologie-Ding zurückzukommen. Ich glaube halt, das ist ein sehr spezifisches Problem auch von Deutschland. Also ich war zwischendurch irgendwie in Dubai. Und dann noch ein bisschen Sonne zu haben und so immer den Laden dann mal so anzugucken. Und die haben ja so einen völlig unverstellten Technologie-Optimismus mit irgendwie allen Nebenwirkungen, die da halt irgendwie so auftreten, inklusive jetzt gerade, wo es ein bisschen geregnet hat und die da irgendwie alles abgesoffen ist, weil sie nicht daran gedacht haben, dass man vielleicht doch irgendwie die Abläufe für den Regen groß genug machen sollte. Aber wenn die halt irgendwie von einer geilen neuen Technologie hören, dann sagen die ja cool, probieren wir mal aus, investieren wir mal und die gehen halt mit so einem Venture-Kapitalisten-Mindset ran. Da sagt halt der Staat so, ja, von dem, worin wir investieren, wird halt 10 Prozent funktionieren. So die wird halt richtig funktionieren. So und wenn von den anderen 90 Prozent noch so drei oder vier Sachen halt irgendwie so halbwegs funktionieren, dann haben wir halt schon richtig gewonnen. So während hier, was hier passiert ist, hier wird einfach genau nicht investiert. Oder wenn, dann halt irgendwie so Siemens und irgendwie Intel in den Rachen geworfen.
Oder Warta in diesem Fall.
In diesem Warta-Fall ehrlich gesagt, wem willst du das denn sonst geben? Wir haben halt keine anderen Batteriehersteller mehr. Also du erinnerst dich noch so an deutsche Post-Sonnenschein-Blei-Akkus. Die gibt es halt auch nicht mehr. Also wenn man halt irgendwie Batteriehersteller haben will, dann ist halt Warta schon eine okay gute Wahl. Und ehrlich gesagt, finde ich es auch in Ordnung, wenn der Staat dann an der Stelle mal sagt, okay, wir helfen dem Unternehmen mal über die Hürde drüber, dass es halt irgendwie Massenproduktion anfangen kann, wenn es sich nicht hundertprozentig sicher ist, ob es zum Beispiel gegen chinesische Konkurrenz bestehen kann, weil die Investitionskosten so hoch sind. Aber das ist halt so eine Ausnahme in dem Sinne, dass eine systematische Förderung von Innovationen und Industrie in Europa ist halt immer so diese, immer dieselben alten, irgendwie holzverteidigte Vorstandsetagen-Konzerne.
Wir haben doch jetzt die Bundesbehörde für Sprung Innovation. Wie hieß der Name nochmal?
Sprint. Die sind eigentlich tatsächlich ganz cool.
Der Name war doch so lächerlich. Wofür schwann das nochmal?
Sprung Innovation, ja genau. Die sind aber tatsächlich erstaunlich cool, weil die haben halt eine Bundesagentur für Sprung Innovation. Also wenn du dir deren Investments anguckst, da ist halt schon so einiges an so richtiger proper Sci-Fi-Tech dabei. Also die sind durchaus mutig und ich finde das sehr cool.
Unbedingt, das ist ja auch deren Job.
Genau, das Problem ist halt nur, dass die in Bürokratie ersticken. Also es ist halt irgendwie auch so, also es ist völlig, völlig hanebüchen. Aber davon haben wir halt viel zu wenig von so was. Also und jedes Mal, wenn so ein Politiker irgendwie Leuchtturmprojekt sagt, dann willst du ja eigentlich erst mal sofort wegrennen. So und die sagen halt, okay, wir investieren wenigstens. Das ist ja schon mal irgendwie ein Fortschritt.
Aber wir gucken mal, vielleicht wird ja was draus.
Aber das haben wir halt einfach viel zu wenig. Und ein Gutteil davon hat auch einfach mit unserer Steuergesetzgebung zu tun, die ja dazu führt, dass halt irgendwie hier zu investieren. Und er lohnt halt eigentlich auch nicht wirklich. Muss man leider so sagen. Und dann ist das schon mal gut, wenn wenigstens irgendjemand irgendwas macht.
Aber hast du auch dieses Gefühl, dass es sich irgendwie vom Fahrgefühl her einem Videospiel annähert? Oder ist das nur bei mir?
Naja, ich kenne Fallout jetzt nicht.
Es muss ja nicht Fallout sein. Also es gibt einfach so ein paar Tropes aus Videospielen. Also ein typisches Trop ist einfach, du kommst in eine Welt rein und alle Institutionen funktionieren nicht. Und alle haben triviale Probleme, die du so nach Leveln in Quests aufteilen kannst. Du kannst dann so eine Questreihe durchgehen und am Ende hast du irgendwie Organisation A irgendwie fahrfähig gemacht.
Du meinst so was wie einen Führerschein in Berlin beauftragen, nachdem du eine Meldbestätigung verloren hast und dein Vermieter nicht erreichbar ist?
Ja, das ist jetzt schon ein höheres Level. Aber so dieses Grundgefühl, dass alles um dich rum kaputt ist und nichts braucht irgendwie tatsächlich Arbeit, sondern so eine Fetch-Quest erreicht irgendwie. Trage dieses Dokument zur Behörde A. So ist eine typische Fetch-Quest. Oder hole irgendwie von da drüben, was weiß ich, den Eimer ab. Also lauter so Sachen, wo du dich fragst, wieso steht das denn hier alles rum, bis ich komme und diesen Eimer bewege? Wieso ist das hier noch voller Leute hier? Also dieses Gefühl habe ich in letzter Zeit häufiger, dass ich halt Decke baue. Das ist ja echt wie im Videospielen hier. Nichts, alles völlig dysfunktional. Und dann komme ich und mache hier irgendwie so ein bisschen, weißt du, und dann kommt noch dazu, also bei Videospielen ist Fetch-Quest inzwischen stark negativ belegt, weil es einfach heißt, die haben irgendwie keine Fantasie gehabt wie...
Kein Story-Writing.
Genau. Und aber wenn du mal mit dem Finanzamt interagierst, das ist ja eine einzige Fetch-Quest. Aber du musst irgendwie den Beleg hierfür. Genau, bring mir das irgendwie. Und denkst du so, warum steht hier alles, bis ich dieses scheiß Dokument von da nach da trage? Gibt es da nicht irgendwie, hätte man da nicht einen besseren? Wo sind die, die Story-Schreiber, die das besser machen können?
Das ist doch so ein Ding, wo ich mich jedes Mal frage, ihr redet jetzt seit 20 Jahren von E-Government. Und ja, es gibt da Probleme mit Privacy und so, und bestimmte Sachen wollen wir auch nicht in so alles richtig. Aber an vielen Stellen bedeutet E-Government in Deutschland ja, dass man einen Scheißprozess digitalisiert und dann halt einen digitalen Scheißprozess hat.
Nee, schlimmer noch.
Was dann halt noch schief geht, wie jetzt gerade eben, wo das Kraftfahrzeugbundesamt diverse Online-Verfahren wegen massiver Sicherheitsbedenken wieder zugemacht hat.
Nee, aber es ist ja noch schlimmer, finde ich, weil du kriegst ein Verfahren, was früher so war, dass du der Gegenseite einfach gesagt hast, was sie wissen musste. Es ist jetzt so, dass du mit deren verkacktem IT-System wieder agieren musst. Das heißt, die outsourcen auch noch die Arbeit, die die Informationen in ihr Scheißsystem einzugeben an mich. So, da hab ich ja überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Also, da denk ich mir immer so, Leute, da ist jemand für bezahlt worden, dieses verkackte System zu bauen, wo ich jetzt die Eingabe tätigen muss.
Also, ich hab da immer das Gefühl, dass es viel davon halt Absicht ist. Also, zum Beispiel Unibürokratien.
Also, das ist der Teil, der das billiger macht mit Bürokratie, mit Digitalisierung, ist, glaube ich. Die behaupten ja immer, das wird billiger und effizienter, wenn du digitalisierst. Und ich glaube, dass das komplett, dass einfach nicht mehr du das eingibst, sondern dein armer Kunde muss das jetzt eingeben. Das ist das, was es billiger macht. Ja, die Externalisierung an Leute, die eigentlich nix dafür können und die Leute, die aufgeben.
Also ich hab ja, wenn ich Vorträge an irgendwie Unis oder so mache, habe ich ja jedes Mal mit deren Reisekosten Bürokratie zu tun. Und ich bin inzwischen der festen Überzeugung, dass viele von diesen Systemen da sind, darauf ausgelegt, dass man dann sagt, so ist jetzt für die 150 Euro irgendwie mir diese Fahrkarte zurückerstatten zu lassen.
Ist gut, zeitig.
Ist okay, lasst mal. Ist mir jetzt gerade die Zeit einfach nicht wert. Es ist halt so genau das selbe System, wie wenn du bei der Bahn selber die Fahrgastrechte rückerstattung haben willst. Das ist ein prima Beispiel dafür, wie man einen Prozess als Abwehr, als Kundenabwehrprozess baut. Und ich glaube, das wird mit Digitalisierung noch besser.
Ist ja auch bei der Bahn schon so. Hast du so eine Bahn-Card? Hast du, ne? Und die kriegst du ja nicht mehr als Plastik jetzt, sondern die ist jetzt nur noch in der App drin. Und die App ist so gebaut, dass sie dir nicht mehr glaubt, wenn du die gekauft hast, dass du die hast. Sondern jedes Mal, wenn du die App aufmachst, oder so, einmal pro Tag mindestens, läd dir die halt vom Server neu. Das heißt, morgens, bevor du zum Bahnhof losgehst, musst du die erst mal refreshen machen, sonst hast du nämlich die Bahn-Card im Zweifelsfall nicht im Zug.
Wenn du in dem Funkloch stehst.
Und mit dem Deutschland-Ticket ist es genauso. Da sind viele Leute dran gescheitert. Inzwischen ist es so, dass kaum noch kontrolliert wird. Das ist mein Anruf. Einfach Deutschland-Ticket wird ganz selten kontrolliert.
Besser hast du halt einen Screenshot.
Ja. Das ist so der Protip. Man macht einen Screenshot und hat den auch dabei.
Genau.
Das ist ja nicht mal dynamisch der QR-Code.
Es gibt keinen Grund dafür, dass der geladen wird.
Überhaupt keinen Grund.
Ich glaube, sie haben mal irgendwann überlegt, ob sie es irgendwie dynamisch signieren. Also dass sie halt quasi eine tagesaktuelle Signatur daran tackern oder so. Aber ich glaube, das wird noch nicht implementiert.
Nee, also der Grund ist wohl, dass die, da gab es wohl irgendwie Betrug zulasten der Bahn halt. Sodass Leute irgendwie mit geklauten, mit geklauten Kreditkarten irgendwie Karten gekauft haben.
Sagen mir, dass du kein Certificate Revocation hast, ja.
Genau.
Mit deinem Prozess.
Und das heißt, irgendwie was sie eigentlich sagen, wenn sie, also inzwischen ist es sogar so wohl, dass sie auf dein Konto gucken wollen, wenn du ein Abo neu abschließt, über irgendwie, wie heißt diese, Clowner, irgendwie diese, wie heißen diese, Dienst irgendwie ehemals. Also es gibt ja jetzt, seit der Bankenreform, gibt es ja jetzt irgendwie so Firmen, die als Mittelmänner agieren. Wenn du sozusagen bei der Bahn jetzt ein neues Abo abschließen willst, ist mir jetzt mehrfach erzählt worden, dann wollen die gerne deine Kontenzugangsdaten haben, inklusive so PIN. Ja, nah. Nicht bei dir, bei der Banken. Ja, nee, kommt gar nicht in Frage, klar. Aber so. Und Begründung ist, ja, wir wollen gern euch, also dich als Opfer, die lügen sie auch noch ins Gesicht, dass sie dich vor Betrug schützen wollen. Aber es ist natürlich das Gegenteil.
Die wollen sich vor Betrug schützen.
Die wollen gern sich vor Betrug schützen, ja. Aber nun denke ich mir doch, wieso eigentlich, wenn irgendwie die Deutschlandkarte in der App nur nach einem Tag gültig ist und danach neu geladen werden muss, wieso müssen die dann das Konto gucken?
Es gibt keinen Grund dafür.
Sie können es ja dann canceln einfach. Oder noch weitergehend, wieso ist denn das Abo jetzt eigentlich nur monatlich kündbar, wenn die Karte nicht einen Monat gilt, sondern nur einen Tag? Ja, so, dann möchte ich aber auch Tagesgünter kündigen können.
Genau, wenn es darum geht und Dayflat haben.
Also diese ganze Bürokratie geht eigentlich immer nur zu Kosten der normalen Bürger, ja, sondern das ärgert mich schon länger. Aber es gibt noch so ein paar andere Sachen, die auch so langsam zunehmend an Videospiele erinnern. Also bei Videospielen gab es ja häufig die Kritik irgendwie, die warten alle darauf, dass du was machst. Und deswegen gab es einige Versuche, Spiele so zu machen, dass die Welt sich auch ohne deine Interaktion weiterbewegt.
Also so einen eigenen Relikt, der Strom hat.
Und insbesondere bei so Wirtschaftssimulationen ist es immer so gewesen, wenn du, sagen wir mal, irgendwie im Weltraum in dem Sektor nie warst, dann verkümmert die Wirtschaft da, weil du nicht mit denen gehandelt hast. So, das heißt, es gibt so Spiele, da ist es so, dass irgendwie der Karstadt plötzlich weg ist, wenn du da eine Weile nicht einkaufen gehst. Und das hab ich jetzt auch plötzlich in der Realität.
Dass der Karstadt weg ist, wenn du da nicht einkaufen gehst.
Genau, ich geh da eine Weile nicht einkaufen, wo ist der Karstadt weg? Ich so, ah, Mist. So, das ist in Spielen, heißt es halt, irgendwie hier jetzt so eine Gelegenheit gehabt, die du nicht genutzt hast. Aber in der Realität, der Karstadt war jetzt, weiß ich nicht, ob das wirklich die Gelegenheit war, aber so dieses Gefühl, irgendwie, da ist jetzt was weg.
Ich glaube, der Karstadt wär auch so weg gewesen, wenn du da gewesen wärst.
Du weißt ja so, wenn du einmal in dem Mindset drehst, bist du es als Videospiel zu sehen, dann denkst du halt so, aah, jetzt auch in der Realität.
Dann lass uns das doch mal extra polieren. Was kommt denn dann als nächstes?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also ich meine, eine Sache, die mich jetzt schon überholt hat, ist, dass die Boings die Bahn überholt haben in Sachen Kaputtsein.
Naja, nicht wirklich.
Also das hat mich schon geschockt, weil ich dachte, die Bahn kriegt keiner überholt.
Haben die sie prozentual überholt?
Naja, also so vom Gefühl her würde ich jetzt lieber in eine Bahn einsteigen als in eine Boing. Aktuell auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das stimmt.
So dieses, also am Flughafen, ich meine, ich bin jetzt schon seit Jahren nicht mehr geflogen, aber wenn ich am Flughafen wäre und da steht es eine Boing 787, dann würde ich sagen, ich fühle mich gerade schlecht, ich nehme die nächste.
Na, hast du doch gesehen, da hat doch einer von den Skyscanner oder so einer von den großen Flugsuchseiten, hat doch einfach nur eine sehr einfache Sache gemacht, nämlich.
Was du auswählen kannst.
Naja, du, also den...
Da gab es so Buchseiten, so Buchseiten, genau.
Das ist eine Ticketsuchseite, also billige Ticketsuchseite.
Genau, da kannst du halt sagen, aber nicht bulligen.
Warte, warte, Moment, das ist subtiler. Da muss man wirklich ins Detail gehen, wenn wir schon bei Videospielen sind. Weil, was dir, also die Suchfunktion gab es ja schon vorher. Also du konntest das vorher schon raussuchen, mit was für eine Maschine fliege ich, weil wenn du halt häufig fliegst, dann weißt du auch, in welcher Maschine sind welche Sitzreihen irgendwie besser und schlechter und so weiter. Also wo hast du eine Notausgangsreihe und so weiter. Die war aber eher so in so einem Pro-User-Interface. Irgendwo so ein bisschen nicht so. Dann haben die die einfach nur nach vorne auf die Frontseite getan und halt gesagt, ich will aber nicht mit diesen Maschinen fliegen. So und die waren halt, ich glaube, das war Skyscanner, die sind groß genug, oder Kayak, einer von den großen jedenfalls, die sind groß genug, dass sie, dass es halt einen Impact hatte auf die Airlines.
Also die Airlines halt sagen mussten so, die haben noch keinen Cent gesehen, den sie sparen können, der ihnen nicht gefallen hätte.
Genau.
Das heißt, die steigen jetzt auf Airbus um, oder was passiert da? Das kannst du auch nicht mal eben machen.
Nee, das kannst du nicht eben machen, sondern die sind ja auch auf Jahre hinaus ausgebucht. Also das ist halt keine Ahnung. Also ich glaube, die spüren es halt jetzt. Die spüren es halt jetzt. Und ich bin halt gut. Also jetzt hat ja Boeing einen neuen CEO und dieser neue CEO, wie war das? Ist der ehemalige Chef von dem, von dem Outsourcer, der sie reingeritten hat, also der sozusagen die Schuld nehmen musste, weil Spirit war ja ursprünglich sowieso mal Boeing und...
Genau, aber das war so der Teil, den haben sie halt in eine eigene Firma getan, damit der sparen kann und...
Das war deren Bad Bank, ne?
Gut, das ist ja jetzt Interpretation. Aber ja.
Also ich hatte den Eindruck, dass es so deren Produktionsbad Bank war.
Naja, aber wenn es die Bad Bank, also nicht 100 Prozent, sonst hätten sie da ja nicht mehr gekauft, sondern nur noch an die Konkurrenz liefern lassen. Also aber ja, das war so der Teil, wo sie gesagt haben, okay, da können wir sparen. Und das war dann aber nicht gut, ja, weil die haben das der eigentliche Sündenfall war wohl der Zusammenschluss mit McDonnell Douglas. Weil die die Leitung von McDonnell Douglas war halt bekannt dafür, dass sie jeden Cent zweimal umdrehen und die Leitung von Boeing war bekannt dafür, dass sie nicht wollen, dass ihre Flugzeuge abstürzen. Und McDonnell Douglas hat halt gewonnen. Ja und der Chef, der jetzt gehen musste, kam von McDonnell Douglas und der neue Chef kommt von Spirit, die noch schlimmer sind.
Also was die halt sind, haben halt irgendwie das McDonnell Douglas Spirit halt irgendwie weitergetragen.
Also Boeing will man auch die nächsten Jahre eher vermeiden, das war die Meinung.
Also interessanterweise gibt es ja in so Großkonzernen, die sind ja so ein bisschen wie Kontinente und da gibt es dann immer noch so so kleinen Staaten, die trotzdem funktionieren. Und da gibt es also bei Boeing, die heißt, glaube ich, Advanced Engineering Division. Und die machen dann sowas wie die...
Gangfarks, ja.
Ja, genau. Die machen dann halt sowas wie diesen, diesen XFB, also diesen Mini Space Shuttle, der automatisch fliegt, der immer so super mysteriöse Missionen fliegt und so.
War das nicht dieses Hypersonic-Tink auch? War das nicht auch von Boeing?
Genau. Und so Zeug machen die da halt. Und die, also was man wohl so hört, ist wohl diese Division funktioniert wohl deswegen, weil sie also nur dem Namen nach zu Boeing gehört. Also die wird wohl halt irgendwie mit der, hier können sie nicht weitergehen, National Security vor dem Management, also vor dem eigentlichen Boeing-Management sozusagen. Also da sind halt die ganzen Greybirds, die halt irgendwie National Security Skunkwork-Kram machen. Und die sagen dann so, ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, hier nicht weiter optimieren tut uns leid. So, ihr kriegt ihr das ja auch in Profit. Und schönen Tag noch so. Geht mal da drüben irgendwie Flugzeuge abstutzen lassen. Wir machen ja richtiges Zeug.
Ja, du, also ich meine, ich habe mir überlegt, es gab ja diesen es gab ja diesen wohl publizierten Fall, dass Donald Trump mit Boeing so ein Deal gemacht hat für die neue Air Force One von ein paar Jahren. Und Boeing hat zugestimmt und sollte irgendwie drei, drei Flugzeuge liefern und hat es nicht geschafft, irgendwie gute Flugzeuge zu liefern, die den Anforderungen genügt hätten. Und da ging es dann immer so durch die Presse von wegen ha ha, der Donald Trump kann doch gut verhandeln so nach dem Motto oder irgendwie ja, kaum prüft mal jemand, sieht man, dass Boeing scheiße ist, so nach dem Motto. Aber ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, ja, wie ist denn das? Kann es nicht sein, dass Boeing das gemacht hat, um die irgendwie an den Eiern zu haben? Weißt du, wenn du irgendwie als Präsident im Boeing Flugzeug rumfliegst, dass Boeing sagt, schönes Flugzeug haben sie da.
Das ist ein Prestigething.
Ja, natürlich auch, aber so schöne Air Force One haben sie da. Wär ja schade, wenn die runterkommen.
Was hätten sie sonst machen sollen?
Keine Ahnung. Das wäre schon geil gewesen, wenn die Air Force One von Boeing, von Elvis gewesen wäre.
Ich glaube, das wäre nicht gegangen. Das wäre nicht ein Lacher gewesen. Also da haben die Amis dann glaube ich noch so ein bisschen Nationalstolz. Also ich meine, das war ja schon schlimm genug, dass irgendwie die DDR-Führung irgendwie in französisch und Zitronens rumfahren musste. Also ich glaube, das wäre nicht, das geht nicht, das geht nicht. Nee, da sagen die lieber, bohingi sollen sich mal zusammenreißen und irgendwie da halt nicht, nicht fuschen.
Gut, aber es gibt noch so eine Sache aus Videospielen, die ich in letzter Zeit auch zu beobachten glaube. Da gibt es nämlich so ein Grundproblem bei Videospielen, dass du ja lauter Gegner hast oder du hast lauter Probleme. Und wenn du hochlevelst, dann sollen die Probleme ja auch schwieriger werden. Und jetzt ist eine der Fragen in Videospielen, wie verhinderst du, dass irgendwie so ein frischer Level-1-Spieler versehentlich zu den schwierigen Problemen läuft und sofort getötet wird. Und eine der Varianten, in die wir spielen, so die Billigvariante ist, sagst du einfach, die ganze Welt skaliert mit dem Spieler. Also wenn der Spieler zulegt, werden die Monster automatisch überall größer. Und das gilt so als cheap. Das ist so die Billiglösung. Eigentlich macht man das nicht. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass die Welt so funktioniert. Oder zumindest sieht sie so aus, dass sobald du ein Problem gelöst hast, kommt halt das nächste Problem. Und das ist dann halt ein bisschen höher. Die Probleme werden immer nur größer. Während ich hochlevel, werden die Probleme immer größer. Ist wahrscheinlich rein irgendwie. Naja, fühlt sich nur so an.
Ich denke schon, dass es eher so ist, dass du zum einen hast du Exis zu größeren Problemen. Also so halt so dieses Problem, dass die Weltgeschichte auf dem eigenen Schreibtisch stattfindet, ist schon irgendwie unangenehm. Und das andere ist halt irgendwie, glaube ich, dass die Komplexität der Welt schon zunimmt.
Na, aber die kann noch früher nicht so viel einfacher gewesen sein. Das wäre ich nur irgendwie nicht gesehen haben. Nee, doch.
Also einfach anzuhören, Menschen.
Kann es sein, dass ich einfach heute mit mehr Problemen in Berührung komme? Und früher war das so, da hat sich halt jemand gekümmert?
Klar, ich meine gut früher, keine Ahnung, warst du halt Student irgendwie so und hast halt irgendwie gezockt so. Und deine Welt war halt im Zweifel so kompliziert, wie du es dir ausgesucht hast. Und irgendwie heute hast du halt eine Firma und eine Familie und irgendwie.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich inherent hochlevelt. Aber so dieses Gefühl, irgendwie ständig mit irgendwelchen Problemen konfrontiert zu sein, ist das neu oder ist das reden wir uns das vielleicht auch nur ein? Also es gibt ja so eine, gerade beim Klimawandel gibt es ja so eine Fraktion von Leuten, die glauben irgendwie, das ist alles nur hochgeschrieben von irgendwelchen Journalisten. Das ist gar nicht so schlimm und irgendein Genie wird kommen und uns raus techen, ja so. Und ich frage mich manchmal, ob da vielleicht was dran ist, dass wir uns einfach selber irgendwie die Probleme schlimm reden und eigentlich, also jetzt nicht den Klimawandel, aber andere Probleme, dass wir einfach immer so tun, als seien es alles schwierige Probleme. Weil ich habe nämlich beobachten können, dass die, also wenn du zum Beispiel ein bisschen irgendwie, also du wirst in Firmen eigentlich nie Leute finden, die rum eideln, sondern die haben alle irgendwas zu tun, was dann zwar inhaltlich eideln ist. So, aber es ist nicht so, wenn du zehn Leute mehr einstellst und die haben eigentlich nichts zu tun, dass die dann da rumhängen, sondern die finden halt irgendwas.
Die machen irgendwas, dass es so aussieht.
Es findet sich was um die Zeit zu füllen, will ich sagen. Und was nach Arbeit aussieht.
Also in Dubai ist es so, ne? Genau, erzähl mal. Ich lese dann immer gern die lokale Presse, um halt irgendwie so ein bisschen so den Überblick zu behalten, was da so passiert. Und das ist ja so ein echtes Königreich. Also sozusagen dem Scheich, da gehört halt der Laden und der regiert den Laden halt auch. Und der ist also vollständiger, absoluter Herrscher.
Ist das ein Micro-Manager oder hat der da einen fetten Bürokratieapparat?
Der hat einen sehr fetten Bürokratieapparat und die haben als Credo, dass sie sagen, wir wollen, dass wir in allem die Besten sind. Das ist sozusagen deren Ziel.
Das finde ich einen guten Anspruch.
So und der macht dann halt so so ein performatives Micro-Management. Also die fahren dann halt irgendwie so.
Kim Jong Un looking at things?
Nee, schlimmer. Die machen also ein bisschen mehr krasser. Also die machen halt so Sachen, also wenn man jetzt der Presse trauen darf, dann fahren die so ein paar Tage die Woche irgendwie fahren die morgens los zu einer zufällig ausgewählten Behörde und tauchen dann morgens.
Was machen die denn hier gerade? Zeigen sie mal hier.
Zur Dienstbeginn auf und lassen sich halt irgendwie Zeug zeigen und gucken, ob alle da sind. Und wer dann zu spät kommt, kann schon mal direkt nach Hause gehen. Und wenn die halt dann Leute sehen, die nicht arbeiten, dann werden die halt direkt gefeuert. Und zwar so unannounced. Und ist dann auch wirklich nur dann so der Scheich und zwei Berater. Also nicht irgendwie so ein riesen Kavalkade oder so.
Funktioniert das? Also ich meine, das wird natürlich so ein Lebensgefühl des Terrors erzeugen, aber funktioniert das inhaltlich?
Na ja, inhaltlich hat das halt schon so ein paar interessante Ergebnisse. Also zum Beispiel ist halt so, die haben halt alles, also deren E-Government ist halt privacy-frei. Na also da gibt es halt also Privacy, es existiert da halt jetzt so in dem Sinne nicht, was ihnen dann halt so ein paar Sachen erlaubt. Zum Beispiel ist so, dass du jede Interaktion mit einer Regierungsbehörde oder regierungsbesessenden Institution, also was halt irgendwie dazu gehört, bekommst du halt dann in deiner Citizen-App eine Aufforderung, die Transaktion zu raten. Das ist halt, ich glaube, von 1 bis 6 Sterne. 1 bis 5 oder 1 bis 6 Sterne oder so. Jedenfalls kannst du halt alles raten.
Die Amazonisierung der Welt.
Naja, und wenn halt aber ein Mitarbeiter oder ein Beamter halt unter einem bestimmtes Level fällt für eine bestimmte Zeit, dann wird halt sein Squaw reset-ed und hat dann auch mal eine Bewährungs-Setter nach, wird da gefeuert. So und zwar alle, inklusive Polizisten. Da muss man auf Reddit gucken, da gibt es dann so Leute, die ihre Verhaftung raten. So irgendwie so. Ja, irgendwie waren freundlich, die Handschellen sind nicht zu fest angezogen gewesen. Der Poliz Cruiser, also das Polizeiauto war irgendwie sauber und die Aircondition in der Restzelle gingen auch und so und also war okay.
Und gibt es da einen Schwarzmarkt aus irgendwie, wir raten dich hoch, wenn du dringend bessere wird?
Weiß ich nicht genau, also könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es sowas gibt, aber weiß ich nicht. Aber oder zum Beispiel war dann gerade so ein Ding irgendwie, da war halt irgendwie so ein von der Regierung betriebenes Krankenhaus. Was halt super schlechte Ratings hatte und auch obwohl objektiv schlecht war. Und da ist er dann da hin und hat sich das angeguckt und oder der Kronprinz, das weiß ich gar nicht mehr, jedenfalls irgendeiner von den aus der Herrscherfamilie in der Hinsicht angeguckt, hat mit den Leuten geredet, den Patienten und so. Und hat dann halt irgendwie angeguckt und so, also der Gesundheitsminister oder der Staatssekretär für Krankenhäuser verbringt jetzt da die nächsten sechs Monate und bringt den Laden auf Vordermann. Wenn er es nicht schafft und die Ratings nicht besser werden, wird er gefoert und der Laden zugemacht. Die machen halt dann so Sachen wie, dass sie dann so sagen, wenn diese Behörden nicht funktioniert, machen wir sie zu, kaufen uns den besten Behördenleiter weltweit oder besten Behördeleiterinnen weltweit. Für diese Sort Behörde machen sie wieder auf.
Aber die werden doch nie irgendwie eine Knappheit an Ausreden haben, warum jetzt die Ratings schlecht sind. So viel Geld oder so.
Ist aber egal.
Also kriegst du dann auch mehr Geld, wenn du sagst, das ist scheiße, weil wir mehr Geld brauchen?
Musst du schon begründen, glaube ich. Aber sie sagt, das ist eine Autokratie. Also klar gibt es seit Dutzende Lächer Bürokratie und bla und kram und so. Also es ist halt irgendwie schon ein richtiger Staatsapparat. Aber so am Ende ist es halt ein richtiger König. So im Sinne von dem gehört der Laden und der kann machen, was er will. Und was dann halt dazu führt, dass zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, einen neuen Führerschein, klickst du halt in deiner App und dann klingelst du ein paar Stunden später an der Tür und du kriegst deinen neuen Führerschein in die Hand gedrückt.
Wir haben ja so eine ähnliche Story hier mal gehabt, als der Willy Brandt die Transit-Autobahn gefahren ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst. Willy Brandt, damals Kanzler, fährt durch die Transit-Autobahn durch die DDR und nimmt halt mit irgendwie, also hier sind überall Schlaglöcher und die Grenzen sind nicht, sind irgendwie unfreundlich. Und dann, sobald es halt jemanden betrifft, der da irgendwie ein bisschen Druck machen kann, hat er halt Druck gemacht und es führte dann dazu, dass die Strecke zwischen Berlin und Hamburg irgendwie neu gemacht wurde, auf Kosten des Westens. Weil er fand, das geht hier nicht, so die Schlaglöcher, das kann man nicht. Also die Grenzen waren natürlich immer noch nicht unter seiner Kontrolle natürlich und die Autobahn selbst auch nicht, aber da hat die DDR natürlich kein Problem mit gehabt, wenn irgendwie der Westen eine neue Autobahn zahlt.
Die haben auch nie eine Westenmark gesehen.
Genau, so. Die anderen Transit-Autobahnen blieben scheiße. Also die nach München waren legendär schlecht. Also das ist, glaube ich, nicht nur in Autokratien so. Du musst halt einen aus der Führungsregel dazu kriegen, dass er das Problem am eigenen Leib erfährt, und dann wird das auch gefixt.
Meinst du, ein bisschen so ähnlich wie mit den EU-Ruhrmengen? Ja, genau.
Das war so, was für eine Rechnung kriege ich hier ran?
Nee, nee, nee.
Also da müssen wir jetzt mal...
Na gut, es ist halt philosophisch wiederum eine interessante Diskussion. Weil halt irgendwie sozusagen dieses... Entweder hast du halt einen Prozess und einen Mechanismus, der dafür sorgt, dass die Sachen funktionieren, oder du brauchst halt irgendwie persönliche Verantwortung, die halt dafür sorgt, dass Sachen funktionieren. Und diese... Also was ich halt interessant fand, so auf der philosophischen Ebene da, war halt, dass die Challengen halt den Anspruch des Westens zu sagen, du brauchst halt Demokratie und Freiheit und Menschenrechte, damit deine Wirtschaft funktioniert. Was also die implizite Ansage des Westens ist, sondern wir sind hier der goldene Westen, weil wir haben Demokratie und Menschenrechte. Und unsere Meinungsfreiheit und unsere Werte. Und deswegen ist unsere Wirtschaft auch geil. Und unser Kapitalismus funktioniert besser. Und die sagen halt so, holt mal Bier. So ist es wirklich so. Weil gut, ich meine deren Wirtschaft ist halt funktioniert halt. Also haben sich jetzt Nischen im globalen Wirtschaftssystem gesucht, die jetzt nicht jedem offen stehen.
Aber na ja, vor allem haben sie halt Nachschub durch die Petrodollar.
Also die müssen jetzt nicht mehr so viel. Die machen nicht mehr so viel mit. Nee, nee, das ist tatsächlich so, dass der Großteil der Kohle, die sie machen, ist halt Tourismus, Finanzdienstleistungen und Geschäfte, Handel, also Handelsgeschäfte und...
Ja, man hört immer wieder, dass irgendwie, wenn der Iran was importieren will, dann kauft es halt Dubai.
Das ist halt eine, sie sind halt irgendwie eine Händler-Nation. Traditionell, traditionelle Händler-Nation. Und nee, es ist tatsächlich mit Öl, es ist primär in Abu Dhabi noch. Also die anderen Emirate, die machen halt schon noch viel in Öl und Gas. Dubai jetzt nicht mehr so viel. Die machen halt ganz viel das Geld der Welt annehmen, damit sie halt irgendwie Apartments in Dubai kaufen. Das ist halt irgendwie so ein großer Teil des Businesses da.
Hast du denn das Gefühl gehabt, vom Fahrgefühl her, das funktioniert?
Interessant ist halt die Stimmung. Also alle, mit denen ich da gesprochen habe, bis runter zum Taxifahrer, zu dem Security Slash Consortium in der Apartmentanlage und so, alle hatten eine persönliche Aufstiegs-Narrativ-Vision. Also wenn ich jetzt hier noch so und so viele Jahre das und das mache, dann kann ich mir den nächsten Level leisten. Also Taxifahrer, wenn ich jetzt hier noch zwei Jahre irgendwie 14 Stunden am Tag Auto fahre, dann habe ich genug zusammengespart, um mir ein eigenes Auto kaufen zu können. Und dann kann ich meine Familie holen. Oder der Concertschalt, wenn ich irgendwie noch hier so und so lange buckele, dann werde ich irgendwie Supervisor und dann kann ich mir irgendwie ein großes Appartement leisten und so und so weiter. Also die haben halt alle. Und dann bis hoch zu den Leuten, die halt davon gründen und finanzieren und Kram. Und die haben halt alle so eine Vision von, wie es ihnen persönlich besser gehen wird, wenn sie härter arbeiten und oder mindestens genauso hart arbeiten, wie sie momentan arbeiten. Und was ich so gesehen habe, was zumindest die Leute mit sich geredet haben, war jetzt nicht die unterste Unterschied. Es waren jetzt nicht die Knuffer auf der Baustelle, die in irgendwelchen Arbeitscamps in der Wüste leben. Aber selbst für die gibt es immer noch irgendwie so eine Aufstiegsperspektive, so eine, so eine, irgendwie einen Grund, wieso sie da racken.
Und hast du das Gefühl gehabt, dass das Fuß in der Realität hat, die Idee, dass es geht wirklich nach oben?
Ja, also das Wachstum ist brutal.
Also, weil das ist ja eine Sache, ich rede ja auch gern so mit mit Taxifahrern, wenn ich in irgendwelchen anderen Ländern bin. Und das ist eigentlich sehr selten, dass du da irgendwas Positives hörst. Immer nur so, ja, ich mach das halt, weil irgendwie.
Nee, nee, also das war wirklich, wirklich frappierend und auch unerwartet, dass also diese, diese, dieser Zukunftsoptimismus war natürlich ein krasser Kontrast zu Berlin. Und die bauen halt auch wie blöde. Man ist halt, der Verkehr ist völlig irre. Du hast halt irgendwie so zweimal sechsspurige Autobahnen und der Verkehr ist so, dass du halt, also halt so quasi so Silicon Valley Style, nur dass alle halt irgendwie ständig 120 fahren und den Sicherheitsabstand nicht kennen. Und das ist halt schon ein bisschen crazy so. Und das ist halt auch so Zero History. Also alles ist halt neu. Es gibt halt irgendwie keine nichts Altes irgendwie. Oder wenn da wirds abgerissen, weil es halt irgendwie Wolkenkratzer aus den 70ern sind, die dann halt weg müssen, weil halt was neu dahin kommt. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es halt auch so so Shadowrun. Also das ist halt also die die die so die großen Konglomerate, die dann halt so die die neueren großen Viertel betreiben. Die haben halt ihre eigenen Police Forces, die halt so Delegated Authority haben.
Das ist ja echt irgendwie das ist ja echt.
Und dann gibt es halt so Geschichten, so wie das Leute dann erzählen, so ja irgendwie dann bekamen sie halt irgendwie in ihrer App, die halt zu ihrer Wohnung gehört von diesem diesem Hochhaus, wo sie da drin wohnen. Naja, es ist halt praktisch, weil du halt sagen kannst, ok, der Mühlschlucker funktioniert nicht. Und dann mal eine Klimaanlage muss mal gewartet werden oder so. Das funktioniert halt auch bidirektional. Dann kriegst du halt irgendwie ein Foto von deinem Balkon. Mit dem Hinweis, ja, da steht so viel Kram drauf.
Und eine Drohne aufgenommen oder wie?
Und räumen mal den Kram runter wegen Brandschutz und so.
Wegen Brandschutz geht ja noch. Weißt du, in Kalifornien und Florida gibt es so Regelungen, dann der Rasen muss gemäht sein. Weil irgendwie sonst sieht das scheiße aus. Nicht wegen Brandschutz, es gibt keinen Grund dafür. Einfach nur fuck you.
Ja, nee, nee, das ist nicht...
Also es hat im einen schon einen Grund dann bei denen.
Also tatsächlich ist es so, dass deren gesamtes Überwachungssystem ist halt immer so kalibriert, dass sie versuchen, dich nur zu belästigen, wenn es einen guten Grund gibt. Also deshalb, das fand ich sehr erstaunlich. Also dass halt alles immer eine Begründung hat, die auch offen kommuniziert wird. Und also sozusagen der Benefit dafür, dass du halt komplett überwacht bist, wird dir auch immer klar gemacht. Und mein, das kulturell ist halt auch irgendwie krass. Also du hast halt so, wenn du da ins Café gehst, ich war zuerst total verwirrt, so als ich hat's schon mal gesehen, hab ich wieder vergessen, gehen Leute ins Café, legen ihr Telefon auf den Tisch, um den für sich zu reservieren und gehen erstmal pinkeln. Und niemand hat die Erwartung, dass der Tisch weg ist belegt oder das Telefon weg ist. Mental gibt's nicht. Das ist halt so eine andere Art des Umgangs. Dagegen kommt dir dann Berlin schon ein bisschen so vor wie der Slum im Videospiel. Auf der anderen Seite hat es natürlich halt irgendwie so dieses ganze, okay, Meinungsfreiheit hat halt so ihre klar definierten roten Linien so, also halt irgendwie, denn die Herrscherfamilie zu kritisieren, ist jetzt nicht so eine weise Idee da.
Aber die hatten auch noch einen Internetfilter landesweit, war das nicht so? Irgendwie Pornos und so wegfiltert.
Genau, aber deswegen haben die Leute alle VPNs.
Also das heißt, wenn sozusagen alle Maßnahmen irgendwie hergeleitet werden, fühlt sich das auch nicht wie Faschismus an für die Leute oder doch?
Also für die meisten Leute, mit denen ich geredet habe, nicht. Also für einige Leute schon, aber für die meisten Leute, mit denen ich geredet habe, nicht. Die sagen halt einfach, guck mal, bei uns funktioniert es halt besser. Also es ist halt so.
Ja, also das war ja für mich ein transformativer Moment, als ich mal in Shanghai war und dann halt die Leute da gefragt haben, so wie ist denn das hier? Und keiner von denen meinte irgendwie, ja, das ist aber scheiße, dass der Staat hier alles kontrolliert hat. Selbst auf das Social Scoring angesprochen. Ja, endlich macht das mal einer. Weißt du so, wir müssen hier mal was tun gegen die Leute für die Schmarotzer. Ja, so nach dem Motto, irgendwie wenn du den Leuten nicht in den Arsch trittst, dann wird es ja nicht besser und jetzt endlich. Und das ist doch eine schöne humane Methode, weißt du, weil da kannst du ja reagieren, ohne dass dich jemand hauen muss. So und das finde ich immer spannend, weil es halt doch, es gibt halt so Sachen, die wir nicht so wahrnehmen, die aber eigentlich doch das Ergebnis von einer Aushandlung sind. Ja, so was wir als irgendwie festes Wertegerüst empfinden, ist halt so fest eigentlich nicht. Selbst innerhalb Europas, also in Schweden ist es ja so, dass die Steuerdaten der Bürger einfach öffentlich sind. Und die haben jetzt auch nicht das Gefühl, dass der der Staat mit seinem irgendwie Springerstiefel ihnen den Nacken zur Straße tritt.
Kennen schon Leute, die irgendwie ihre Fremden aus Schweden verlagert haben, weil sie genau dieses Gefühl haben.
Wegen des Steuersatzes und nicht wegen der...
Nee und auch weil sie halt sagen, okay es geht halt eigentlich niemandem was an, was ich da tue und ich kann ihn nachvollziehen.
Okay, ja okay.
Also es ist halt, aber letzten Endes aber trotzdem diese Art und Weise des Umgangs des Westens damit. Also diese Überheblichkeit zu sagen so, unser System ist besser.
Wir haben die Weisheit mit Löffeln gefressen.
Weil unsere Werte und so. Und dann kommen die natürlich und sagen so, naja, also dann machen wir doch mal genau dieselben Zensurgesetze wie bei euch, nur halt mit unseren kulturellen Attributen. Und was wollte denn jetzt eigentlich?
Das finde ich auch mal krass, wie unsere Presse dann darauf reagiert. Ja, das geht aber hier nicht Menschenrechte und so. Und dann nenn ich so, warte mal, habt ihr nicht RT zitiert, zensiert? So, ja, also wir machen natürlich das.
Oder halt eine Chat-Kontrolle, genau, was das Spiel so. Wo du denkst, okay, vielleicht tut es dem Westen irgendwie dann doch mal ganz gut, dass es da auch noch so wirtschaftlich erfolgreiche Autokratien gibt, die halt diesen Narrativ-Challengen und mal sagen so, okay, jetzt beweist doch mal, dass eure Werte wirklich so essenziell sind, dass sie halt wirklich das sind, was die Leute glücklicher macht, dass die Leute irgendwie zu einem zufriedeneren Leben bringt. Und ich meine, ich würde mir wünschen, dass das der Westen diese Challenge hat. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es schon so, dass das Narrativ des Westens mit seinen Werten und halt der Freiheit und der Meinungsfreiheit und so und der Liberalität und so weiter, dass es halt irgendwie genau so lange funktioniert hat, wie es halt diese Wettinnen gab. Also dass solange die halt diese Wettinnen als Gegner da war, denen man es halt zeigen musste, hat es halt funktioniert. Und jetzt ist aber so, dass wo man eigentlich genau dasselbe mit China machen müsste und mit den mit den mit den sonstigen Autokratien, wo man sagen muss, okay, wir beweisen euch jetzt mal, dass man Demokratie und Menschenrechte braucht, damit es besser ist, die Leute zufriedener sind und besseres Leben haben. In dem Augenblick ist gerade der Westen halt irgendwie die breitflächigste am Versagen. Und das nervt mich gerade sehr, weil es halt einfach quasi die Idee von Menschenrechten und Humanität und irgendwie dem Wert des Individuums und der Freiheit des Einzelnen und seinem Recht auf Privatsphäre, die sind mir halt extrem wichtig. Und ich finde nicht, dass der Westen halt da einfach so sich damit abfinden sollte, zu sagen so, ja, na gut, okay, hat nicht funktioniert. Wir machen jetzt halt nur Kapitalismus und tun da noch so ein bisschen so, als gäbe es da halt noch so ein bisschen liberale Freiheiten. Aber irgendwie, das war halt leider nur irgendwie Deko.
Naja, also was mir halt richtig klar geworden ist in China, ist, wie wenig von der Wahrheit durchtröpfelt zu unseren Medien. Denn wenn du hier über China liest, hörst du nichts davon, nichts davon aus dem Eindruck, die Leute werden alle irgendwie unterdrückt. Und jetzt, wo du von Dubai erzählst, muss ich daran denken, wie also was mich sehr schockiert hat in den USA, als ich erfahren hab, dass irgendwie nur ein Drittel der Bevölkerung überhaupt einen Pass hat. Weil die einfach noch nie das Land verlassen haben. Aber trotzdem sind sich alle einig, irgendwie greatest nation on earth. Und ich denk mir halt, wenn ich dich jetzt aus Dubai zählen höre, dass wir eigentlich dasselbe gerade machen. Also wir reisen vielleicht innerhalb Europas rum, aber das ist ja alles homogenisiert weitgehend. Das heißt, so die tatsächlich anderen Modelle kriegen wir gar nicht mit. Und wenn wir mal Gelegenheit haben, könnten sie mitzukriegen, dann verhindert sozusagen die Presse, dass wir da mal eine neutrale Berichterstattung kriegen. Weil wenn wir hier in der Presse über Dubai reden, hören wir ja, die haben da moderne Sklaverei von den Bauarbeiter und so. Das stimmt ja alles. Aber wir hören halt nicht die Teile, die unser Narrativ challenging könnten. Und so ist es mit China auch. Und ich frage mich jetzt halt, ist das mit mit wie vielen anderen Ländern ist das auch so? Ich habe schon länger das Gefühl, ich habe schon länger das Gefühl, dass die Berichterstattung aus dem Iran nicht vertrauenswürdig ist. Also wahrscheinlich ist das auch sehr schwierig. Aber alles, was wir hören, ist halt negativ. Und ich denke mir, da wird es auch irgendwas Positives geben. Also ich denke mir halt, aber das erodiert halt das Grundvertrauen in die Presse. Ja, wenn die, wenn wir nämlich an den beiden Stellen schon belügen, dann glaube ich in den Rest halt auch nicht mehr.
Das Phänomen hat man ja sowieso immer, dass man halt in dem Augenblick, wo man mal first hand weiß, was wirklich passiert ist, und dann die Presseberichterstattung dazu liest, dann wundert man sich halt immer schon, wie es da, wie es mit dem Rest aussieht. Aber ich glaube bei diesen...
Aber nur sehr kurz, oder? Ist dir das mal aufgefallen? Du blätterst um und da ist Artikel über Thema B, und denkst, oh, alle werden nicht schon wissen. So, nee. War ja nicht genauso scheiße.
Also mir geht es halt immer so, dass diese, dass mir die Differenzierung in der Berichterstattung, insbesondere in der deutschen Presse, wirklich stark fehlt. Also das ist halt einfach so dieses, man muss nicht ein ganzes Land runterschreiben, nur weil da halt ein paar Sachen scheiße sind. Na also das ist halt so eine, ist halt nicht viel besser als wie, wenn RT über Deutschland berichtet. Die schreiben halt auch ein ganzes Land runter.
Also das können sie schon machen, aber weißte ich nicht. Ich finde, das können sie schon machen, solange sie den Rest auch erwähnen, aber das tun sie halt nicht.
Genau. Aber Differenzierung meint eben auch, dass man ein vollständiges Bild liefert. Ja. Und das ist halt so, das ist in der deutschen Presse halt, insbesondere, also die deutsche Auslandsberichterstattung ist ja sowieso stark runtergefahren, sind denn nur sehr wenige tatsächliche Auslandskorrespondenten unterwegs. Und die liefern natürlich auch, was die Redaktionen zu Hause hören wollen. Und wenn man dann mal halt irgendwie Medien liest, wie zum Beispiel Economist, die halt noch ein echtes Auslandskorrespondenten Netzwerk haben, die halt auch unterwegs sind und die halt eben auch durch eine differenzierte Berichterstattung liefern können, dann sieht man halt auch, was gehen könnte. Also dass es halt nicht notwendig ist, dass es auch nicht so ist, dass es halt es irgendeinem Grund unmöglich wäre, halt eine differenzierte Berichterstattung über, was in anderen Ländern passiert zu machen. So und diese, diese, ich glaube, dass so ein bisschen das Problem eine Selbstverstärkung ist. Also dass halt in dem Augenblick, wo man jetzt mal anfängt zu sagen, so okay, man berichtet jetzt mal was Positives über Dubai oder was Positives aus dem Iran, dass du dann sofort natürlich halt die Truppenteile am Hals hast, die aber dir sagen so, ja, aber die haben da moderne, die haben da moderne Sklaverei. Und genauso könnte man halt über Deutschland, wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie die deutsche Welleberichterstattung über Deutschland siehst, die ja auch relativ positiv geneigt ist, um es mal vorsichtig zu formulieren. So, dann kannst du natürlich hingehen und sagen so, aber hier, guck mal da, irgendwie die Obdachlosen und irgendwie die Drogensüchtigen und den offenen Crackhandel in der U-Bahn in Neukölln und so weiter. Also du kannst natürlich mit, wenn je nachdem, wie du deinen Fokus setzt haltet, das gesamte Bild halt ändern. Und dadurch, dass alle genau nur noch das machen. Also sozusagen so die AfD berichtet halt irgendwie, die rechten Medien, Yatsi Tzuhanko oder Don Alfonso, die berichten halt nur noch irgendwie aus dem Berlin-Slam, wie es halt irgendwie, also die schlechten Teile so. Und irgendwie die grün geneigten Medien berichten halt irgendwie von den tollen Fortschritten, weil wieder ein Leuchtturmprojekt von irgendeinem minderer Bedeutung irgendwo in der Provinz aufgemacht wurde, weil ein Minister da neben grinsen konnte. So und das ist halt irgendwie so ein Ding, da fühle ich mich ehrlich gesagt von allen Sachen nur noch verarscht.
Das ist so eine der wenigen Sachen, wo ich sagen würde, so eine der wenigen Sachen, wo ich sagen würde, da haben die Amis uns noch was voraus. Die haben nämlich noch so eine Trennung zwischen Berichterstattung und Op-Ed. Das heißt, in der Zeitung ist markiert, das ist jetzt hier Meinungsartikel und zu Meinungsartikel zählt auch so Einordnung. Und das sind Nachrichten. Also die Trennung ist jetzt nicht toll.
Vor allen Dingen sind nur noch in sehr wenigen Medien der Fall.
Aber als Konzept finde ich das gut, denn bei uns ist das alles eine Soße. Und wenn du ein Artikel...
Nicht unbedingt. Also es ist halt so, dass die Tagesshow zum Beispiel versucht, diese Trennung schon zu machen. Die haben ja explizit den Kommentar. Also dann meistens aus irgendeinem der unteren ARD-Anstalten.
Von der Bayerischen Rundfunk.
Genau, denn der Kommentator vom Bayerischen Rundfunk sagt wieder irgendwas dazu.
Zur Cannabis-Legalisierung.
Aber es ist halt irgendwie nicht... Aber wenn man sich zum Beispiel spiegel.de anguckt, da ist halt der Unterschied zwischen Meinung und Berichterstattung halt nicht mehr gegeben. Und das ist halt irgendwie auch so für die auch Absicht. Also die sagen ja, dass sie das als Haltung im Journalismus bezeichnen. Ehrlich gesagt ist mir da...
Ist wie die Werte bei Springer.
So, das finde ich irgendwie langsam nicht mehr angemessen. So weil ich will gerne wissen, was wirklich passiert ist und so möglichst differenziert. Und die Meinung lese ich dann auch noch gerne dazu, aber erst nachdem ich gelesen habe, was wirklich passiert ist.
Na, ich denke halt, wenn du das trennen würdest, dann hättest du mehr Spielraum, um eine Berichterstattung zu machen über die Sachen, die nicht ins Narrativ passen. Weil die meisten Kritiken sind ja nicht an der Berichterstattung, sondern an dem Op-Ed-Teil. Wenn du das also in der Zeitung ordentlich trennen könntest, dann hättest du, glaube ich, einen Spielraum, um über den funktionierenden Kapitalismus in Dubai zu reden, ohne angekackt zu werden, weil du nicht, und dann eher wahrscheinlich, vielleicht wirst du doch angekackt, aber nicht so viel.
Du wirst immer angekackt.
Aber halt nicht so viel, als wenn man sagen könnte, der vertritt hier eine Meinung. Wenn du sagst irgendwie, hör mal, das hab ich gesehen, hier sind die Bilder.
Na Moment, der Punkt ist folgende, die Erwähnung von nicht ins globale, narrativ passenden Tatsachen führt immer dazu, dass du angegriffen wirst.
Ja, aber jetzt, das ist schon ein Intensitätsunterschied, oder?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, überhaupt nicht. Also, nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel so Klimatechnik. Also in dem Augenblick, wo halt irgendjemand zum Beispiel über Carbon Capture und Storage berichtet, ist halt, da kann der Artikel noch so differenziert sein, okay, das ist irgendwie eine Technologie, die weit in der Zukunft liegt, sie ist nicht energieeffizient. Die Mengen, die da irgendwie rauskommen, sind irgendwie vielleicht eher so minder. Aber geil, wir haben jetzt immerhin den Fortschritt, dass wir es schon mal zumindest grob ans Laufen bekommen haben und es nicht mehr Labormaßstab ist.
Wir haben jetzt Level 1.
Wir haben jetzt so Level 1 und da kommen halt noch viele Level danach, bevor es irgendwie relevant werden könnte. Und erst wenn wir keine Infusion haben, wird es überhaupt sinnvoll, das irgendwie zu benutzen. Trotzdem kriegst du dann so die Vorwürfe von wegen so, ja, wieso berichtet ihr überhaupt darüber? Da hättet ihr doch über ein tolles Solarprojekt berichten können, in dem gleichen Platz, als wenn der Platz im Internet irgendwie begrenzt wäre. So, dann kommt der Vorwurf irgendwie, ja, da wird auch nur Hoffnung mit geweckt, irgendwie, dass irgendwie diese tolle Technologie uns irgendwie aus der Krise techen würde. Selbst wenn da dreimal drin steht, diese tolle Technologie wird uns nicht aus der Krise techen, kriegst du diesen Vorwurf, ja?
Ja, also ich meine, ich verstehe ja auch, wo die herkommen, weißt du, die Leute, die diese Kritik bringen.
Aber die haben verhindert, dass wir uns darauf vorbereiten, dass wir vom Klimawandel getroffen werden. Diese genau dieselben, genau dieselben Leute haben, haben, haben dafür gesorgt, dass wir mit die Geischen von unsere Städte auf den Klimawandel vorbereiten, 20 Jahre zu spät anfangen. Das wird halt einfach richtig viele Leute das Leben kosten. Ist halt so. Und die haben diese Form von Engineering und Diskussionsverweigerung führt halt dazu, dass wir halt nicht in der Lage sind, das, was wir tun könnten als Menschheit wirklich zu tun. Weil immer dieses irgendwie, ja, lass uns diese Technologie mal lieber irgendwie nicht technologisch betrachten und nicht darin investieren, weil dann könnte ja irgendjemand glauben, dass man mit dem Klimawandel irgendwie klarkommen könnte. So anstatt jetzt anzufangen, halt irgendwie CO2 zu sparen. Und wieso kann man nicht sagen, wir machen halt beides, was soll der Scheiß? Wir müssen beides machen, alles andere wird uns nicht zum Ziel führen. Ich hab da irgendwie keine Geduld mehr für. Das ist halt irgendwie so einfach so dieses, diese borniert halt irgendwie auf allen Seiten, dass man halt nicht irgendwie mal ein differenziertes Bild der Realität machen kann und daraus halt irgendwie ein differenziertes, multifacetiertes Handeln ableiten kann. Ich weiß nicht, wo die Leute das verlernt haben. Ist das in Videospielen, ist das vielleicht auch, ich hab das von Videospielen, weil in Videospielen immer alles nur so eine, ein Ding ist. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ein Quest und eine Handlung.
Eigentlich ist es nicht, nee, aber es gibt eine Parallele, weil in Videospielen gibt es häufig die Möglichkeit, dass es irgendwie eine gute Lösung gibt. Und dann gibt es vielleicht noch fünf nicht gute. Und dann gibt es im Internet irgendwie ein Wiki. Und da steht was auf, du machst das, und dann machst du das, und dann machst du das. Und dann anloggst du die gute Lösung. Und dann ist klar, es gibt eine gute Lösung, die machen wir dann alle. Und ich glaube, dass einfach viele so grüne auch so funktionieren, dass die halt denken, okay, es gibt eine gute Lösung. Na den Rest wollen wir dann natürlich nicht. So, aber diese Sicherheit hast du halt nur in Videospielen, dass es eine gute Lösung gibt.
Weil die schon 200 Leute durchgespielt haben.
Nee, nicht nur deswegen, sondern auch weil es von Menschen gemacht wurde als Szenarien. Und die wollen natürlich, dass es eine gute Lösung gibt.
Determinierst du schon.
Also es gibt einige Ausnahmen, es gibt auch Videospielehersteller, die möchten gern, dass alle Lösungen scheiße sind. Es gibt es auch, aber selten. Es ist wie mit Hollywood-Filmen, die meisten werden einfach ein Happy End haben. Und deswegen guckst du dir das ja auch an, weil du gern Hoffnung haben willst. So, aber diese Sicherheit, das finde ich immer der Teil, der mich daran ärgert, diese Sicherheit von den Leuten, dass sie wissen, wie wir da jetzt rauskommen. Wenn sie es überhaupt nicht wissen, sondern dass es einfach irgendwie Hoffnung ist. Ich meine, ich finde es ja schön, dass Leute noch Hoffnung haben. Aber du weißt es halt nicht. Vielleicht kommt morgen jemand, der findet irgendwas. Wir sollten jetzt nicht auf den warten, aber wir sollten die Hoffnung auch nicht aufgeben. Und wir sollten auch Leuten nicht verbieten, an Dingen zu forschen, die uns möglicherweise retten können.
Letzten Endes ist es halt so, das kennt man eigentlich auch so Open-World-Games, um mal wieder bei der Videospielperspektive zu bleiben, dass du halt eigentlich nur dann gewinnst, wenn du dir möglichst Optionen offen hältst. Also dass du halt irgendwie immer dafür sorgst, dass du deine Med-Packs und deine Munitionen hast und weißt, wo deine Karte und dein Kompass sind.
Und wenn es dir mit keiner Fraktion richtig verdurbst. Verscherzt.
Ja, genau.
Und dann siehst du aber, wie die Leute in der Realität reagieren und die verscherzen sich mit allen, die nicht 100 Prozent auf ihrer Linie sind. Wundern sich dann, dass nichts bei rauskommt. Dann denke ich mir so, Leute, lernt doch bitte alle Lektionen aus dem Spiel. Ja, also eine Sache, die ich immer als Hebel versuche, ist, dass ich so Kampfbegriffe einfach auf das Gegenteil anwende. Ja, zum Beispiel, wir hatten jetzt Modern Slavery in Dubai. Ja, und dann habe ich also mal irgendwie gefragt, ja, haben wir eigentlich auch Zwangsarbeit in Deutschland? Und es stellt sich raus, ja. Also ich meine, natürlich haben wir irgendwie Sachen, ich habe dann so was wie Hartz IV als Zwangsarbeit bezeichnet, aber wir haben auch richtig so gesetzlich Zwangsarbeit, zum Beispiel für Knasthäftlinge. Ja, und so. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir keine Sklaverei haben, die heißt nur anders bei uns. Und das ärgert mich daran, wenn die Leute in Dubai über Sklaverei reden und dann aber das bei uns irgendwie per Begriffswahl als andere Kategorie kategorieren. Und das ist ja was irgendwie was ganz anderes. Das ist ja nicht vergleichbar. So, weil wir haben ja eine Demokratie, wir haben ja Werte. So, ja, nee.
Na gut, ich meine, da könnte man jetzt irgendwie an dem spezifischen Beispiel, da könnte man schon rumkritteln.
Ja, natürlich kann man immer rumkritteln, aber ich finde immer, du kannst irgendwie anderen Leuten Fehlverhalten nur vorwerfen, wenn du das nicht auch machst. Da bin ich einfach, da stehe ich auf so.
Also, ich meine, also, sagen wir mal Knasth-Zwangsarbeit ist also, da kann man halt sagen, ok, da hat der Rechtsstaat dafür gesorgt, dass die Leute in den Knast kommen und diese Arbeitspflicht ist Teil der Strafe, ist was anderes als jetzt am Anfang.
Nee, das ist ja gerade nicht die Herleitung. Das ist nicht die Herleitung, nee. So, der Staat kostet irgendwie der Knast Geld und dann kann er sich das auch zurückholen, indem er die Leute zum Arbeiten zwingt.
Ok, aber die Leute sind aber...
Der Knast ist nicht als Strafe gemeint, sondern als Resozialisierung.
Die Leute sind aber in diese Situation durch ein rechtsstaatliches Urteil gekommen. Die sind nicht in diese Situation gekommen, weil ihnen jemand in Karatschi am Flughafen gesagt hat, willst du Geld verdienen, steig einen irgendwie...
Ja, nee, aber weder der Knast aufeinteilt, noch die Zwangsarbeit ist als Strafe gemeint im Rechtsstaat.
Na gut, aber es gibt sozusagen eine rechtsstaatliche Institution, hat ein Urteil gefällt, was zu dieser Situation geführt hat. Wie auch immer die jetzt am Ende im Detail konfiguriert ist. Versus halt, was der Vorwurf bei der Sklaverei in Dubai oder in Katar ist, ist ja quasi, dass die Leute getäuscht werden in Arbeitsverhältnissen, die halt de facto Sklaverei sind. Das ist halt schon noch ein anderer Twist. Moment, ich bin noch nicht fertig mit dem Moment. Aber es gibt natürlich jede Menge andere Sachen, wo man halt diesen Vergleich schon durchaus ziehen kann. Und das sind halt irgendwie diese alles, was halt irgendwie so diesen gesamten Bereich Regierungsentscheidungen und Bürokratieentscheidungen angeht, wo die, sagen wir mal, die Willkür des Beamtenapparats, also wenn jetzt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, du bist in so einer Kafka-Falle gelandet im Finanzamt, wie ist das für einen Fetch-Quest, so, ne?
Genau.
Da gibt es ja welche, die funktionieren nicht. Also die haben keine gute Lösung. Also wo du halt zum Beispiel Steuern zahlen musst auf einen theoretischen Gewinn, den du nie gemacht hast. Was dir passieren kann zum Beispiel, wenn du halt irgendwie Angestellter bist und du hast halt irgendwie Aktien bekommen von deinem Unternehmen, irgendwie, wie es in jedem vernünftigen Land der Welt irgendwie sein sollte. Und dann werden diese Aktien plötzlich bewertet und du musst Steuern zahlen auf Geld, was du nie bekommen hast. So kann dir halt passieren. Und da gibt es halt keine Lösung. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit. Und du läufst dann halt gegen Barrieren, wo du halt denkst, okay, gibt es hier nicht irgendjemand, der mal eine Entscheidung fällen kann? Und die Antwort ist nein. Es gibt niemand, der dir aus dieser Lage helfen kann. Das sind halt irgendwie Tar Pits in der Realität, wo du halt, wenn du nicht davon weißt, und die sind halt häufig genug gut verborgen, dann hast du halt einfach Final Pech gehabt. Und zwar so richtig Final Pech gehabt. Und so eine Sachen gibt's da halt auch. Nur die sind halt anders strukturiert. Gibt's aber dann im Zweifel noch jemand, der sagen kann, okay, lass mal mal. Na also, ist gut, kann's gehen. Und dieses Nicht-Einsehen-Wollen, dass alleine die theoretische Genese des Prozesses, nämlich, dass er halt irgendwie aus einem Gesetz entstanden ist und dieses Gesetz ist irgendwie demokratisch legitimiert und danach gibt's halt noch irgendwie Gerichte und Oversight und so weiter. Dass das nicht zwangsläufig immer zu einem besseren Prozess führt, allein dieses zuzugeben und daraus irgendwie einen Optimierungswillen abzuleiten und zu sagen, okay, wir versuchen einfach mal, unsere Probleme zu fixen und dafür zu sorgen, dass wir halt nicht eine Situation haben, wo die Leute in solche Tar Pets laufen können oder wo die Leute sagen, okay, warum soll ich hier eigentlich noch in diesem Land investieren? Weil ich habe ja eigentlich gar nichts mehr davon. Dieser Willen, den gibt es halt hier nicht. Das ist eigentlich das, was mich wirklich, wirklich nervt.
Ich finde auch immer schwierig, diese Begrifflichkeiten. Spätestens jetzt, wo wir aus Russland hören und die sagen dann, ja wieso? Wir haben doch ein Parlament. Die haben das demokratisch abgestimmt. Es gibt hier ein Gesetz, es gibt Gerichte, die die Gesetze irgendwie kassieren könnten. Die haben auch kein Problem damit gehabt. Diese Begrifflichkeit wird immer hier benutzt, als wenn daraus schon irgendwie eine Sakrosanct wie Unantastbarkeit folgt. Aber die Russen können natürlich genauso behaupten, ihre Prozesse seien demokratisch gewesen. Also wissen wir natürlich, die Wahlen sind manipuliert, so okay geschenkt, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass der ganze Mechanismus irgendwie in Russland kompromittiert ist automatisch.
Also ist dann wahrscheinlich schon.
Natürlich, aber so einfach zu sagen, ja das ist doch aber demokratisch legitimiert, das reicht mir inzwischen auch nicht mehr.
Ja, also insbesondere, weil halt irgendwie hinreichend viele Staaten jetzt halt einfach diese ganze Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit, Cosplaying halt irgendwie perfektioniert haben.
Ja, so genau, selbst innerhalb der EU.
Ja und ich meine, also gut, vor dem EU-Parlament mal.
Ja gut, nee, aber es gab diese schöne Formulierung auf Englisch, das ist halt eine a matter of degree, not of category. Ja, das meinte ich vorhin, der modernen Sklaverei. Natürlich ist es nicht dasselbe, wenn wir hier irgendwie ein Knast dazu zwingen, irgendwie Arbeit zu machen. Da kann man irgendwie Begründungen finden, aber können die halt auch, weißt du, wenn die sagen, na ja, wir haben den ja nicht ins Land irgendwie entführt, sondern wir haben dem halt den Pass abgenommen und es stand hier im Kleingedruckten. Dieser Art von Prozess habe ich hier auch schon erlebt. Ja, so also nicht, dass dann der Pass weg war, aber so. Ja, wieso? Das stand doch im Kleingedruckten. Das haben wir hier auch. So und das heißt halt für mich, das ist im Wesentlichen eine vergleichbare Kategorie, aber die Frage ist halt, wie tief du reingreifst in die Kaladisation. So wie schlimm. Und da, finde ich, sind wir viel zu unsensibel, wenn es bei uns um Verfehlungen geht und viel zu sensibel, wenn es darum geht, bei anderen auf Verfehlungen zu gucken. Aber was ich dich noch fragen wollte, du warst ja auch in Saudi-Arabien, oder hast dir da die Wand an? Nee, aber du hast diese Wand irgendwie verfolgt, die die da bauen wollen. Erzähl doch da mal von.
Ja, also die hängt halt einfach damit zusammen, die Saudis haben so ein Großprojekt, das heißt NEOM, und NEOM ist halt ein riesiges Investmentprojekt, was in der ganzen Region, unter anderem halt auch in Dubai, halt so unter den Leuten, die da halt Business machen, so Tagesgespräch ist, weil halt so viele Unternehmen daran hoffen, beteiligt zu werden, also dass sie halt irgendwie da was zu liefern. Also was die Saudis da planen, ist dann ziemlich abgefahren eigentlich. Die sagen halt, okay, wir haben halt hier ein Problem mit dem Klima, obviously, also im Sommer wird es da halt richtig warm. Deswegen bauen die im äußersten Nordwesten, also quasi in der nördlichsten Region von Saudi-Arabien am Meer, eine, ja, neue Stadtkonglomerate. Und eines davon ist The Line.
Das ist ein Megaplex, würde man sagen, im Shadowrun.
Genau, im Shadowrun wäre es ein Megaplex. Eines davon ist halt The Line. Und The Line ist halt so ein, quasi Snowpiercer in Architektur gegossen. Snowpiercer ist dieser Film, wo die Reichen vorne sind, im Zug und hinten in die Arme.
Ein immer fahrender Zug.
Genau. Und nur, dass bei denen ist es halt Architektur. Es steht halt am Meer, in der Wüste. Er war quasi so perpendicular vom Meer weg.
Und 170 Kilometer lang war die ursprüngliche Planung.
Genau, das ist die ursprüngliche Planung. Inzwischen ist Ihnen wohl aufgefallen, dass es gewisse Schwierigkeiten gibt, also 170 Kilometer lang und irgendwie 200 Meter breit, glaube ich, oder 500 Meter. Das ist jedenfalls gigantisch.
Und auch mehrere Stockwerke hoch.
Viele Stockwerke hoch. Also richtig hoch, 400 Meter hoch soll es sein. Also richtig.
Und da sind dann alles drin, was du so zum Leben brauchst.
Genau, das ist Self-Contained City. Und das ist halt das eigentliche Ding in der Ernährung, ist halt, dass sie sagen, wir machen City as Technology, also quasi entwickeln halt lauter Zeug oder lassen entwickeln lauter Zeug, was du halt brauchst, um eine Stadt unter den Bedingungen dieses Jahrhunderts halt zu haben. Das heißt also draußen ist unangenehm. Du musst halt self-sustainable sein, musst deine Wasserversorgung zirkular haben, du musst deine Energieversorgung irgendwie im Griff haben. Du musst halt irgendwie deinen Transport ohne Autos organisiert bekommen. Du musst irgendwie genug Grünflächen haben, Schulen, Kindergärten, Shopping und so weiter und sofort haben, Freizeiteinrichtungen. Also quasi so ein bisschen so was, die übernächste Generation von so den Ideen, so von Oscar Niemeyer City Blocks, die halt also diese quadratischen Blöcke sind, die sie in Brasilien zum Beispiel gebaut haben und nach denen auch zum Teil halt die Neubauer Blöcke in der DDR gebaut wurden. Also wurde quasi ein quadratischen Block hast, in dem halt ringsrum die Wohnungen sind, in der Mittagstown-Schule, Kindergarteneinkaufszentrum, Sportplätze, Erholungsstätten, Altenheim und so. Also so eine, also diese Idee sozusagen weiter, so self-contained city, aber dann halt als lang gestrecktes Gebilde. Aber das Interessante daran ist eigentlich, dass sie innerhalb von diesem Neoprojekt auch noch lauter anderes Zeug machen. Also zum Beispiel hat sie automatisierte Fabriken oder hoch automatisierte Gesundheitswesen, Einrichtungen, also wo sie quasi sagen, wir gehen jetzt mal all in und investieren richtig Geld und wir sorgen dafür, dass jede Menge andere Leute auch richtig Geld investieren. Also die haben halt ziemlich viele Investment zusammen von außerhalb davon. Also der Line ist nur der sichtbarste Teil von diesem ganzen Großprojekt. Und das ist halt so ein bisschen so die Idee, halt irgendwie so Sprunginnovation im Bereich Stadt zu machen oder überhaupt so.
Halt nicht nur als Forschungsprojekt, sondern gleich zu sagen, wir bauen das dann auch.
Genau, wir bauen das dann.
Das muss auch funktionieren. Das ist nicht nur ein Paper, was wir haben.
Genau, das muss ja noch funktionieren. Inklusive, da kommen dann kuriose Probleme bei raus, wie zum Beispiel brauchst du halt Fahrstöder, die es halt vorher noch nicht gegeben hat, in Größenordnungen und Geschwindigkeiten, um halt irgendwie so ein Ding am Laufen zu halten und so. Und unten drunter ist dann halt ein Data Center und so. Also schon ziemlich ambitioniert und groß. Inzwischen haben sie, glaube ich, ein bisschen von der Länge her gesagt, okay, wir bauen erst mal nur die ersten 20 Kilometer oder so. Das ist auch schon viel mehr als überhaupt ein Beton und Stahl und Glas zusammenkriegst in der Gegend. Aber die Interessant darin ist halt quasi dieser Sprung zu sagen so, okay, wir leben hier in der Gegend. Die wird mit dem, wo wir momentan Architektur haben, vermutlich in absehbarer Zeit nicht mehr so bewohnbar sein, zumindest im Sommer. Wir müssen was bauen, wo wir einen Großteil unserer Bevölkerung reinholen können. Also quasi so ein Arcology, wo halt irgendwie Überleben in dieser Region möglich ist und wir brauchen ein Businessmodell dafür. Daraus resultiert halt dieses Neumdick. Und Dubai hat dann halt gesagt so, ja holt mal Bier.
Machen wir.
Und haben sich ein Stück Ägypten gekauft am Mittelmeer.
Der gute Teil, ja.
Das sind so ziemlich, ziemlich coolen Teil von Ägypten so. Und machen da halt Dubai 2.0. Also halt genau dasselbe. Also man sieht da halt so diese Konzepte von so Territalität und Staatlichkeit und Vermengung zwischen Konzernen und Staaten kriegen halt ganz neue Dimensionen, die halt viel offener sind als im Westen. Also im Westen hast du ja so quasi so die die großen Konzerne, die eigentlich im Wesentlichen halt so den Westen ausmachen. Und da ist halt diese Verbindung zwischen Konzern und Staat offener und viel viel enger und viel selbstverständlicher.
Wobei das gab es ja lustigerweise in den USA von der anderen Seite, dass so ein paar Libertäre gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt hier, wie ist das, Charter City oder so. So wir kaufen jetzt irgendwie diese Gemeinde hier sozusagen alle Häuser und dann sorgen, machen wir die Verwaltung, wir stellen die Polizei, wir machen alles. Wir wollen dann aber auch die Gerichtsbarkeit haben innerhalb der.
In Dubai ist es halt so, dass die großen Immobilienkonzerne, die also dann halt irgendwie so diese großen Viertel betreiben, wo du dann halt hier so einen Partnern kaufen kannst, die sind halt so richtige Shadowrun Empires. Also die haben halt ihre eigene Polizei-Force, die halt innerhalb der Anlage halt auch bis zu einem bestimmten Level an Kriminalität und so halt für Ordnung sorgt. Also Delegated Authority und dann halt die die staatliche Polizei erst involviert, wenn es halt schwere Verbrechen und so weiter sind oder ein Gericht involviert werden muss und so weiter. Oder die den Fall abgeben an die Polizei, damit es dann nicht Staatsanwaltschaft gegen kann und so. Also es ist halt so, aber halt so ein Minor Disturbance sind so Regeln, die halt intern, da wird dann halt irgendwie, die verhängen dann halt auch Strafen innerhalb dieser Anlage. Da schreibst du halt einen Vertrag, wenn du deine Erprachung kaufst.
Stand im Kleingedruckten.
Wo es im Kleingedruckten steht, was du halt dann irgendwie an Fees zahlen wirst und so.
Du meine Assoziation war Raumschiff. Wir bauen jetzt ein Raumschiff, aber auf der Erde.
Das ist genau das, was die tun. Also die haben jetzt da so Regeln, dass bei den, wenn die neue Gebäude bauen in Dubai, innerhalb, in bestimmten Zonen halt, wenn die halt mehr als ein Stockwerk haben, dann müssen die fußläufig klimatisiert mit den Nachbargebäuden verbunden sein. Meistens kommt dann noch ein Mall hin, die die Gebäude verbindet oder die Gebäudekomplexe verbindet.
Und eine S-Bahn.
Die haben sie schon. Sie haben eine Metro, die jetzt, naja, die ist ein bisschen hinterplanen, aber gibt's immerhin. Und jetzt bauen sie The Loop, was einen knapp 100 Kilometer Ring ist, der alle wesentlichen Viertel verbindet.
Wieso mit Vakuum, Tube?
Nee, das ist ein Jogging, Fahrradfahren, Spazieren, Spielplätze und Grünanlage. Also als so ein großer, so eine große Ringanlage. Also 100 Kilometer oder 790 Kilometer, glaube ich, sind sie mit dem Fahrrad im Kreis fahren, wenn du willst. Und du kannst halt, also sie hoffen, dass sie damit halt ihren Verkehr, weil der Verkehr ist wirklich ihr Hauptproblem. Also sie haben halt Autoverkehr, der ist nicht mal irgendjemand aus der Regierung beschrattet, den wohlwollend als okay. Es ist halt so, dass es wirklich ein Problem ist. Du kannst in dieser Stadt ohne Auto nichts machen. Und alles ist immer eine halbe Stunde Autofahrt.
Das erzählt man sich ja auch von Berlin. Also nicht, dass du ohne Auto nicht kannst, aber wenn du in Berlin mit dem Auto von A nach B fährst, bist du immer 45 Minuten unterwegs. Ja, ich muss dir mal von der Dokumentation erzählen, die ich vor einer Weile gesehen habe, die mich seitdem beschäftigt. Da ging es um einen Hochhaus in China. Und die haben sich ähnliche Gedanken gemacht, wie was können wir da alles integrieren, damit du am besten nie das Haus verlassen musst. So und die haben dann so Konzepte gehabt, wie da gibt es ein Fitnessstudio, es gibt irgendwie einen Schwimmbad in dem Haus, es gibt Einkauf, es gibt mehrere Restaurants, Fahrstühle natürlich und unten haben sie dann so ein Postsystem gehabt, das fand ich sehr interessant. Und zwar haben sie so einen Raum mit irgendwie Schließfächern und die sind aber nicht zugeordnet. So jetzt kommt der Postbote und tut da was rein und trägt dann in den Computer ein. Fach 15 ist was für Bewohner so und so. Bei dem bimmelt dann das Handy und dann läuft der halt runter und holt sich das aus dem Schließfach und dann ist es wieder frei. Ja, so. Und dadurch verhindern sie diese Tragedy of the Commons, dass irgendwie gemeinschaftlich genutztes Zeug einfach vergammelt. Weil es ist jeder Teil davon ist halt deiner und du brauchst ihn halt. So und die Schließfächer sind groß genug, dass auch die Restaurants aus dem Ding da rein liefern. Also wenn du irgendwie Sushi willst, musst du nicht zum Restaurant laufen, sondern kannst auch sagen einmal Sushi. Und dann packen wir das in deine Box und dann bimmelt dein Handy und dann fährst du mit dem Fahrstuhl runter in irgendwie, brauchst nicht mal richtige Schulen, sondern du bist im Haus, holst dir das raus und fertig. So und dann, also du gehst halt nur noch raus, wenn du woanders arbeiten musst. Im öffentlichen, alle anderen Sachen sind, es gibt auch einen Zahnarzt und so. So und dann dachte ich mir so, wenn ich sowas denke und wenn ich dich jetzt von hier der Lein erzählen würde, dann machen wir das eigentlich nicht. Wieso denkt bei uns keiner in diesen Kategorien? Ich meine, wir werden ja dieselben Probleme auch haben, vielleicht ein bisschen später, weil wir hier klimatisiert.
Also interessanterweise sehen die uns als Vorbild zum Thema Walkable City. Na ist tatsächlich so, dass also dieses, also was die da tun mit diesen Vierteln, die halt dann quasi mit Malls verbunden sind, ist halt die Idee der Walkable City, auf deren Klimaverhältnisse umgesetzt. Und du hast jetzt schon da halt so in den neueren Vierteln, hast du halt so Malls, in denen es halt Joggingpfade gibt und Fitnessstudios, die in der Mall nicht als so ein Laden drin sind, sondern so in so einem Platz in der Mall so ein bisschen tiefer gelegt. Und du hast immer so Grünanlagen und Springbrunnen und so. Und für die Leute ist es halt wirklich so von der Außenwelt abgekapselter Lebensraum. Und für den Winter gibt es dann halt dieselben Pfade oben noch mal auf dem Dach, wo du zwischen den Häusern laufen kannst. Oder nachts, wenn es halt irgendwie nicht so heiß ist. Und wenn es halt zu heiß ist, dann bleibst du halt unten in der klimatisierten Zone. Und das ist halt so, wir dachten immer, okay, da muss man also große Glaskuppeln bauen und so. Und die machen das halt einfach mit Malls. Also die verbinden halt einfach alles mit Malls. So ist halt irgendwie so, wird halt irgendwie und wie gesagt, in diesem Loop. Ich bin gespannt, wann sie den fertig bauen. Aber die machen dann auch so Quatsch, dass sie dann sagen, ja, und dann bauen wir Energie-Harvesting in den Jogging-Pfad ein. Also das sozusagen quasi das, also gut, das ganze Dickwurt wird mit Solarzellen zugepflastert.
Aber ist doch egal, ja, lass dir das doch.
Ja, genau. Eben, ist doch egal, lass sie doch machen. Also das ist halt so ein Ding, was mir halt hier fehlt, ist halt so dieser Spaß, mal so Sachen einfach mal machen.
Ich finde auch, das ist so einer der wenigen Bereiche, wo Sci-Fi ein bisschen irgendwie zu faul war. Ja, also wir haben dieses Konzept von so irgendwie Mega-Cities haben wir häufiger. Also Cyberpunk ist auch so ein Genre, wo es Mega-Buildings gibt, wo dann Läden drin sind und so. Das ist also keine neue Idee. Aber so wie man dann in dem Gebäude vorankommt, ist eine Sache, wo einfach niemand wirklich irgendwie Konzepte sich überlegt hat. Da gibt es dann halt einen Fahrstuhl und im Videospiel bist du halt der Einzige, der den benutzen muss. Deswegen ist er immer frei. Aber in der Enterprise gibt es den Turbolift. Das ist ja ein ähnliches Problem. Du hast irgendwie Decks und musst halt hin und her. Und da gibt es nie der Fahrstuhl, der ist jetzt voll. Also die sagen Fahrstuhl und dann kommt der Fahrstuhl.
Also in der Realität ist da halt so, ich war halt auch in ein paar so richtig großen Häusern da. Also die sind auch wirklich sehr hoch. Die haben wirklich 90-Stockwerke, 100-Stockwerke oder so.
Ja, dieses chinesische Ding auch.
So, und da haben die dann halt so unterschiedliche Kategorien von Lifts drinnen. Also es gibt dann zum Beispiel, wenn du weiter nach oben musst, gibt es einen Lift, der fährt dann nur bis zur Umsteigeetage. Also weil es gibt halt irgendwie eine Limit.
Das ist üblich übrigens, das haben die Amis auch. Also in Amerika ist es so, du kommst in so einen Wolkenkratzer unten rein und dann gibt es irgendwie einen Lift für Stockwerk 1 bis 20, so eins für 20 bis 40. Und es gibt auch so welche, wo dann gibt es halt einen, der fährt immer nur bis zu einem bestimmten Stock. Genau, und da musst du halt den nächsten irgendwie für die fahren. Also sowas wie die X-Busse in Berlin. Es gibt halt so die Metrobusse, die fahren häufig, und es gibt die X-Busse, die fahren irgendwie immer in jede dritte Station halten die dann.
Und einer der Gründe dafür ist wohl halt auch, dass es halt irgendwie so mit der die Pneumatik von so langen Liftschächten ist wohl ein Problem. Da heißt also, du kannst halt irgendwie diese Röhren, da entstehen dann halt irgendwie so Druckprobleme und Schornsteineffekte und so. Deswegen hast du mehrere in einer Schacht, ne? Nee, deswegen, also die eine, aber zum anderen hast du dann halt eben diese Umschleigetagen, damit du dann halt quasi die Schächte, die von da losgehen noch weiter nach oben, sind dann halt sozusagen pneumatisch getrennt.
Ja, also es ist nicht so, dass überhaupt keine relevante Forschung in Deutschland stattfindet, ja. Also ich hab neulich auch so ein Video gesehen, da ging es um einen Fahrstuhl, der eben nicht nur hoch und runter, sondern auch zur Seite fahren kann.
ein Vertical Lift, ja.
Genau, und sowas brauchst du natürlich auch, wenn du sowas machst.
Ja, Horizontal Lift, ja.
Also eigentlich willst du sowas haben wie der Turbo Lift in der Enterprise. Da sagst du halt, da will ich hin und dann macht der Bülpp und dann bist du halt da. So will man das eigentlich haben. Aber die Forschung müsste halt jemand machen und du müsstest vor allem, brauchst du wahrscheinlich viel mehr einfach Verbindungsraum, um diesen Transport ermöglichen zu können, als man so denkt.
Tyssen hat doch so gena Testanlage von dem Ding laufen. Die haben was da drin.
Ja, aber da passen ja auch nur Endleute rein. Und je länger der Weg ist, den so ein Teil zurücklegt, das entweder brauchst du dann so gondelbahnmäßig halt ganz viele Gefährte und dann brauchst du irgendwie Kollisions- und und Ausweichstrategien und so. Also das ist nicht ein komplexes Problem.
Ja, klar. Aber das ist halt so ein schon.
Aber es wäre schon geil, wenn es irgendwie so ein Konzept gäbe, dass du einfach vor der Tür sozusagen Fahrstuhl hast. So wie man jetzt zur S-Bahn läuft, läufst du halt zum Fahrstuhl. Und der bringt dich dann halt ins Haus 15, Stock 83.
So Rohrpost.
Ja, genau.
Können doch, das ist ein funktionsfähiges System.
Das muss halt jemand mal bauen. Aber diese Idee, dass wir anfangen, unsere Gebäude so zu bauen, dass sie weniger Außeninteraktionen brauchen, das ist irgendwie eine Sache, die ist hier noch nicht angekommen, ist meiner Meinung nach.
Also bei modernen Neubauten jetzt hier zum Teil schon, also dass die halt irgendwie mehr self-contained sind und irgendwie.
Bei uns gilt es doch als Nachteil, wenn du unten Restaurant drin hast oder Supermarkt, weil du dann irgendwie Fußverkehr hast und dann sind da Leute vor deiner Haustür und so.
Also, nee, nee, gut, okay, nee, sowas im Sinne von self-contained so für. Ist ehrlich gesagt auch erst ab einer bestimmten Gebäudegröße, die du in den meisten deutschen Städten gar nicht realisiert bekommst, wegen Traufhöhe irgendwie sinnvoll.
Ja, aber warte mal, bis wir die Mega-Buildings kriegen und die werden wir kriegen müssen, wenn wir nicht genug Häuser bauen. Irgendwann Platz ist alt. Du willst ja hier keinen Bürgerkrieg haben. Wir haben einfach zu wenig Housing. Irgendwann wird jemand kommen und sagen, okay, pass auf, wir bauen jetzt hier mal etwas höher aus.
Die Traufhöhe wird von den Immobilienbesitzern in Berlin mit Waffengewalt verteidigt werden.
Ja, aber in beide Richtungen gibt es dann Waffen.
Bin ich mir sicher. Also wenn die Traufhöhe in Berlin fällt, muss ja nicht für die ganze Stadt sein.
Es gibt halt eine Ausnahme, von mir aus auf dem Pempelhofer Feld, das wird ja eh gerade umkämpft, was man da machen soll.
Ich meine, es gibt ja schon Ausnahmen. Potsdamer Platz.
Stimmt, ja genau.
Potsdamer Platz hat keinen Traufhöhe.
Da baust du dann einfach ein fettes Mega-Building hin.
Der Zoo hat auch keine Ausnahmen. Also im Umkreis um Bahnhof Zoo und im Umkreis um Potsdamer Platz.
Stimmt, da haben sie auch ein relativ hohes Hotel hingebaut.
Und jetzt noch Alexanderplatz.
Aber das ist alles noch weit entfernt von den mega bildigen Visionen aus irgendwie.
Ja, also meine...
Aber da geht noch was.
Da geht auf jeden Fall noch was. Aber ich glaube, dass halt irgendwie die Art und Weise, wie wir uns mit Architektur auseinandersetzen...
Die muss sich noch mal grundlegend ändern.
Ja, also ich meine auch da. Also das ist halt so, was die da zum Teil bauen, ist halt irgendwie auch so völlig hanebüchener Quatsch. Also wo denkst du, wie weit habt ihr jetzt hier eigentlich gedacht? So, ne? Und irgendwie... Dann reißen sie es aber wieder weg. Also wirklich so, dann steht es halt zehn Jahre und sie sagen, ja, war scheiße, reißen wir wieder ab.
Na, ich find ja richtig beunruhigend. Also das kommt jetzt auch aus Land an. Aber gerade so in Amerika und bei uns teilweise auch, findest du so Bauruinen, die halt halb gebaut wurden, die aber nie fertig wurden. Und du siehst eigentlich schon, so hätte ich das gebaut, eher nicht. So. Und dann ist das halt Kapitalismus. So, dann ist in der Mitte halt das Geld alle.
Oder die Baugenehmigung kam nicht, oder was auch immer.
Also gut, das ist ja eher untypisch für Deutschland, dass jemand ohne Baugenehmigung baut, wenn es nicht gerade irgendwie ein flüssig Gras-Terminal ist.
Das ist gut, ich will aber, also in Spanien zum Beispiel, ist das halt ja heute ein wichtiges Wort für Bauruinse. Weil ich war zwischendurch noch in London, also letztes Jahr, und da ist halt richtig hart. Also da ist halt irgendwie so, die Stadt zerbröselt denen da. Also ist halt so, dass irgendwie da fließt teilweise wirklich einfach die Scheiße über die Straße, weil halt irgendwie so die Kalonisation komplett im Eimer ist und niemand da ist, um sie zu fixen.
Du musst auch überlegen, wann die gebaut wurde und für wie viele Einwohner. Also das ist ein Wunder, auch die Tube, die das U-Bahn-System in London ist ein Wunder, wie viel die das skaliert gekriegt haben.
Also mit der Tube, die sagen in der Tube ja immer, gibt es ja so eine Ansage, so eine automatisierte, generierte Ansage, die sagt so, ja und hier an der Station haben wir gerade ein Problem, deswegen musst du, wenn du da und dahin willst, da und da langfahren. Und es mir einmal passiert, dass diese automatisierte Ansage so viele Exceptions enthielt, mit hier ist ein Brand und da irgendwie musst du umsteigen, um da hin zu kommen und diese Line ist gerade geschlossen, dass die nicht in den Zeitraum zwischen zwei Stationen passte. Die hat es nicht geschafft zu loopen, sondern die wurde abgebrochen, weil dann war so jetzt hier die Paddington Station.
Naja, aber es ist ja nicht nur in London, das haben wir eigentlich überall gerade, das Gefühl, dass um uns herum alles vor sich hin bröselt. Die Bahn und Boeing haben wir schon gehabt, aber auch so Zukunftsdinger scheinen gerade der Reihe nach weg zu platzen. Also mein Eindruck ist, die selbstfahrenden Autos haben sich gerade in Luft aufgelöst, oder?
Ich glaube, die sind gerade eher in dem, wenn wir jetzt mal sogar eine Halbzeit nehmen, irgendwie so in diesem Teil des Elends.
Genau. Also du glaubst, die kommen da nochmal raus?
Ja, also da ist ja immer so, wenn man sich anguckt, wer hat die besten Chancen, selbstfahrende Autos zu bauen, dann ist die überraschende Antwort halt Daimler, weil die schon so lange so konservativ da dann rumforschen. Also die haben ja schon vor 20 Jahren eine selbstfahrende S-Klasse gehabt.
Die nennen es aber halt immer irgendwie Assistenzsysteme.
Die nennen es halt irgendwie automatisches Fahrsystem Level 3, Assistenz, blag, also völlig anders stated halt so. Und die sind aber de facto am weitesten was zugelassene Assistenzsysteme gibt die halt irgendwie so und wenn man so guckt, was die so machen und wie weit die so sind und so und vor allen Dingen, dass die halt sagen so naja, wir haben halt einen echten Grund, weil die Leute, die unsere Autos kaufen, sind alle schon ein bisschen älter. Die werden tendenziell auch immer ein bisschen älter.
Und sehen auch schlechter.
Und sehen halt auch schlechter und haben nicht mehr so eine gute Reaktionszeit, aber die wollen halt gerne unsere teuren Autos fahren, weil das ist Teil ihrer, das sind was sie wollen. Und deswegen bauen wir halt Assistenzsysteme da ein, die halt dafür sorgen, dass die auch noch mit 90, wenn sie im Zweifel eigentlich objektiv nicht mehr Auto fahren können, noch Auto fahren. Weil das Auto dann halt für sie fährt. Und die wissen halt ziemlich genau, wie ihre Demographie aussieht. Und deswegen, also wenn man sich so anguckt, so wer kriegt es im Zweifel hin? Das wird nicht Tesla sein, sondern wird Daimler sein. Weil die halt sagen, uns doch egal, wenn wir in so einer S-Klasse nochmal für 5000 Euro mehr Sensoren stecken. Das ist fällig ralle.
Ich meine die Anzahl der Sensoren, weil glaube ich nicht das Problem.
Natürlich. Ja, deswegen ist Tesla so schlecht bei automatischem Fahren, weil die sagten, wir machen es mit Kamera auch nicht. In so einer S-Klasse oder in so einem Porsche hast du halt einfach endlos vier Lieder, Radar, Ultraschall, nochmal zwei Stereokameras drüber. Ich glaube in so einer aktuellen S-Klasse mit anderen dran hast du 14 Kameras, sechs Liders, zweistellige Anzahl Ultraschall-Sensoren, vier Radars. Das ist halt wirklich endlos.
Das ist wie so ein Flugzeug.
Genau. Und du siehst sie halt nicht. Sie sind halt so integriert, dass du sie halt in der Karre nicht siehst. Weil die halt sagen, die Leute zahlen 5.000 Euro dafür, dass wir ihnen das Kamelhaarleder mit einem roten Stich genäht haben. Da können wir auch noch 5.000 Euro mehr für die Sensoren ausgehen. Das ist der einzige Ansatz, wie es zum Laufen zu kriegen wird. Man wird automatisches Fahren nicht for cheap mit irgendwie, wir sparen an den Sensoren oder am Compute zum Laufen bekommen, sondern nur mit Axis-Sensorik und massiv viel Axis-Sensorik.
Am Compute spart ja auch keiner. Das ist mein Eindruck, die haben alle über dir Fetten in die Art Scheißlinge.
Natürlich nein, die sparen wie Blöde. Ich meine, wenn du dir so einen Standard massen Autoproduzenten anguckst.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von VW, sondern von Waymo. Mit diesen Taxen, selbstfahrende Taxen, wo gerade eine gesichtet wurde, die auf der falschen Fahrbahnseite fuhren. Du denkst, die eine Anforderung, bei der ich gedacht hätte, das haben die inzwischen raus, so nicht mal das.
Wahrscheinlich hat jemand das GPS gespufft.
Nee, nix GPS. Das war so eine Straße in Amerika. So ist es nicht so gut genommen, wie bei uns. Das ist viel anders. Da gibt es Straßen, die haben irgendwie eine durchgehende weiße Linie zwischen den beiden rechten Spuren. Und dann gibt es eine doppelte gelbe Linie in der Mitte und auf der anderen Seite nochmal eine durchgezogene weiße Linie.
So was, wenn die doppelte weiße Linie rechts von dir ist, ist irgendwas falsch.
Genau. Also die doppelte Linie sollte nicht rechts von dir sein. Und dieses Auto hat halt die, aber das gibt es halt. Warte mal, gibt es das auch so, dass die mal, ich glaube nicht, dass du die am rechten Rand haben kannst? Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Aber jedenfalls, also die beschreibt es bei Autobahnabfahrten. Bei Habeabfahrten gibt es das.
Das kann sein. Ja, also ich mein, ja, also das Auto hat halt an der falschen Linie sich entlang gehangelt. Ja, so das ist halt scheiße. Aber so dieses Gefühl, dass irgendwie die ganzen Halbversprechen jetzt eigentlich alle geplatzt sind der Weihnacht, das bis auf bei KI, da sind sie noch am platzten. Da sind wir jetzt noch beim Aufstieg. Ja, da hab ich hier so eine Meldung notiert. Da ging es um eine Voice-Aktor-Frau. Die hat halt getweetet, so ja, sie hat gerade eine Absage von der BBC gekriegt. Die brauchen sie nicht mehr. Begründung, sie haben irgendwie Erlaubnis bekommen, eine KI zu benutzen. Das ist natürlich schon scheiße, ne, so.
Und was macht die jetzt?
Naja, was soll sie machen? Irgendwie sich woanders bewerben. Aber die sehen sozusagen die Schrift an der Wand, die wissen, das läuft nicht mehr lange. Und jetzt wird es ein paar normale Act-Boss geben, die jetzt ihre Persönlichkeitsrechte an die KI-Industrie verkaufen. Da gab es schon die ersten. Ich glaube, das wird es einfach sein. Und dann werden wir immer dieselben Leute sehen, weil die haben halt irgendwie, das ist halt auslizenziert.
Das heißt, es wird dann einfach keine neuen Actors mehr geben?
Naja, mit ganz Actors weiß ich nicht, aber bei Voice Actors bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Die bisher sind so die KI irgendwie, oder die Alterungs- oder Verjüngungs-Dinger sind noch nicht so wirklich überzeugend, fand ich. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich eine Frage der Zeit auch.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, was für dieses Harrison Ford-Movie irgendwie...
Das war doch furchtbar. Und bei Indiana Dones, dem neuesten, haben sie ihn versucht, irgendwie 40 Jahre jünger zu werden.
Und das sah nicht gut aus. Sah aus wie gehauen.
Ich hab nur irgendwie gelesen. Ich hab's nicht... Aber gut, vielleicht bin ich da irgendwie zu anspruchsvoll. Keine Ahnung, weil ich zu viele Videos, viele gespielt hab.
Ja, kann gut sein.
Naja, und dann haben wir noch den Trend, dass immer mehr versprechen, sie einfach als Scam herausstellen. Ja, gerade so beim KI Zeug lässt sich gut beobachten, dass da jetzt eine Menge ehemalige Coinscamer, so Bitcoins, irgendwie Shitcoins, die sind jetzt halt zu KI gewechselt. Und es hat sich herausgestellt, die haben eine Sache gelernt, sie müssten nicht mal den Firmennamen aussprechen können. Das Niveau, das du brauchst, um Leute erfolgreich zu bescheißen, ist so tief. Du musst nicht mal irgendwie so die Fachbegriffe richtig aussprechen können. Das reicht, wenn du irgendwie Hals versprechen musst.
Ja, aber ich hab so das Gefühl, dass zumindest die Venture-Kapitalisten so langsam doch irgendwie...
Denen geht das Geld aus. Das ist nicht so, dass die vorsichtiger werden. Die haben einfach so viel Code verbrannt. Ich meine, die sind auch so was wie Hyperloop reingefallen, wo es irgendwie relativ schnell klar war, dass es nie darum ging, ein Fortbewegungssystem zu bauen, sondern das hinaus zu zögern, damit die Leute am Ende Teslas kaufen.
Ja, stimmt. Also gut, es gibt ja irgendwie bei Venture Capitalist gibt es ein sehr breites Spektrum von Klugheit. Die dummen Lemminge sind da auch nicht so wenige. Davon sind tatsächlich einige wirklich auf die Coinbrot-Scammer reingefallen, also zweimal. Einmal irgendwie bei den Coins und dann jetzt irgendwie bei KI. Was auch immer sie KI nennen sollen. Andererseits muss man sagen, es gibt jetzt tatsächlich eben bedingt durch die Menge an Compute, die jetzt verfügbar wird, durch diesen KI. Hype, gibt es halt schon noch Anwendungen, die halt auch sinnvoll sind und die irgendwie wirklich tatsächlich funktionieren im Machine Learning Bereich. Das hat ja nicht alles kaputt.
Machine Learning ist nicht grundsätzlich scheiße. Aber diese ganzen Leute, die gerade rumlaufen, das KI nennen, das ist halt... Aber so dieses Gefühl irgendwie, dass die Hälfte ist Game und die andere Hälfte funktioniert nicht, das wird schon intensiver in meiner Wahrnehmung. Und wir erleben halt gerade, haben wir vorhin schon angesprochen, dass die Banken zum Beispiel als Geschäftsmodell einfach sich komplett vekrationalisieren, weil die braucht man einfach nicht mehr, wenn ich mein Geld abhebe und einzahle in den Supermarkt und es gibt ansonsten keine Filialen mehr. Wozu habe ich dann noch eine Bank? Könnte auch Lidl einfach mir das Konto geben.
Naja, deswegen...
Ich habe das neulich im Blog angesprochen, da meinte jemand, ja, ich wohne in Schweden, da ist das schon so. Da dachte ich so, was? Ja, also der Supermarkt hat halt eine Bank. Du, ist halt... Die hat halt keine Filialen, aber du gehst halt eh zum Supermarkt und dann...
Stimmt, ich meine eigentlich...
Wenn du mal Bargeld brauchst.
Eigentlich ist total logisch, wenn...
Also was soll das auch? Ja eben.
Die drei großen Handelskonzerne sich einfach eine Bankenlizenz holen? Ich meine, die würden die Problemlos kriegen.
Und haben sie sogar schon. Es gibt eine EDEKA-Bank. Die ist nur bisher nicht für Endkunden, sondern für die EDEKA-Mitarbeiter. Ja, so. Also es gibt es schon sogar. Das heißt, es besteht, glaube ich, ziemlich direkt bevor, dass die Banken alle weg sind. Ist ja jetzt schon so, dass die die Kunden alle weg ekeln, weil sie gerne sich konzentrieren würden auf irgendwelche Wails.
Naja, nur dass die halt irgendwie keinen Bock haben, sich irgendwie von diesen Banken ausnehmen zu lassen.
Ja, natürlich nicht.
Tja, naja. Alles ein Scam.
Tja, aber also nicht nur, nicht nur. Es gibt ja so die Art von Scam, dass du Sachen versprichst, von denen du selber weißt, dass du sie nie haben wirst. Aber es gibt halt auch die Art von Scam, dass du Sachen versprichst und dann aber an der Qualität so weit sparst, dass es nicht mehr erreichbar ist. Und das, finde ich, haben wir jetzt auch ein paar Mal beobachten können. Häufig. Ja, und ich denke mir dann immer so, warum bist du überhaupt tätig in so einer Branche, wenn du dann aber nicht irgendwie den Anspruch hast, dass das Hand und Fuß halt am Ende, wenn du irgendwie so viel, ich meine, die werden nicht freiwillig sparen. Da steht wahrscheinlich ein VZ hinter ihnen und atmet ihnen irgendwie den Rücken, ne?
Nicht unbedingt. Also, es ist halt, glaube ich, so, dass eine Menge Zeug gemacht wird von Leuten, denen die Technologie eigentlich egal ist und denen der Service eigentlich auch egal ist. Die wollen halt einfach wirklich nur Geld verdienen und die halt im Wesentlichen ihr Handwerk bei McKinsey gelernt haben und bei McKinsey haben sie halt gelernt, dass man halt irgendwie noch das letzte Zehntelprozent Optimierung rausquetscht und zwar Optimierung an Profit. Und dann hast du halt irgendwie am Ende halt die Produkte, die nur so gerade so noch gut genug sind, um irgendwie halbwegs durchzugehen und irgendwie dem Marketing versprechen, zumindest auf den ersten Blick nicht so komplett entgegenzustehen. Aber in den meisten Fällen ist es halt so wie wenn du halt irgendwie irgendwas bei Wish ordersst, was halt in dem Bild total gut aussieht. Aber leider ist es halt irgendwie was nur das 1-10-Scale-Model.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich glaube fast, dass das eine Sache, die wir von den Chinesen gelernt haben. Da gab es ja immer so die Story.
Die haben das von uns gelernt und nochmal eins weitergedreht.
Ach, also ich habe immer nur die Kritik gehört sozusagen von deutschen Firmen, die in China gefertigt haben und die meinten, okay, du gehst dahin, machst irgendwie Qualitätssicherung und dann einigt man sich irgendwann, okay, das ist jetzt gut genug. Und danach fangen die halt an und sparen wieder und machen es wieder schlechter und dann kriegst du halt tatsächlich, der Kunde kriegt dann was anderes geliefert, als er abgenommen hat. Und so komme ich mir halt auch bei regulären Firmen.
Genau.
Aber das war auch unsere Taktik nur halt stärker angewendet, finde ich mal so.
Genau, die haben halt einfach nochmal eine Runde weitergedreht. So ist das halt so irgendwie necessarisch.
Ja, also McKinsey finde ich ein gutes Stichwort, weil da kam jetzt neulich so ein Artikel an mir vorbei, dass der, also das ist ja gerade so relativ gut wahrnehmbar, dass die Google-Suche immer schlechter wird. Und der Artikel hat halt...
Der war fruchtbar, dieser Artikel.
Der hat erklärt so, ja, Schuld ist jemand von McKinsey. Der halt irgendwie, die haben so einen Ingenieur gehabt, der die Suchmaschine gemacht hat, der hat gesagt, ne, ne, das machen wir ja alles nicht. Ja, sonst ist der Wert der Suchmaschine weg.
Moment, es ging halt primär, ging es darum, wie stark sind die Suchresultate von den Werbeanzeigen, die in diesem Searchspace geschaltet werden, beeinflusst. Das war der wesentliche Parameter. Und dieser Engineer hat da gesagt, unser Credo ist, wir wollen eine Suchmaschine bauen und wir machen die Werbung da drüber.
Und die soll den Leuten helfen und dann können wir Werbung einblenden, um das zu finanzieren.
Genau.
Und die Google-Firma hat aber angefangen zu sagen, nee, pass auf, unser Job ist hier Werbung zu machen. Die Suche ist nachgeschaltet. Das heißt, die Suche macht jetzt Sachen, die Werbung haben will. Und die Werbung wollte natürlich, dass die eingeblendete Werbung nicht aussieht wie eingeblendete Werbung, sondern wie Suchergebnisse.
Und dass halt die Suchergebnisse, die halt irgendwie scammy sind und die halt irgendwie so generiert sind und so ähnlich sind wie die Werbung, dass die weiter oben landen.
Ja, warum? Weil die von Google Ads Werbung einblenden, die Scammer.
Ja.
Also und das war halt auch McKinsey. Das heißt, im Grunde ist es inzwischen so, egal wo du hingreifst, wenn die Branche irgendwie alles kaputt optimiert zu lassen der Kunden, dann ist es wahrscheinlich McKinsey.
Genau, ich meine immerhin haben sie bei der Bundeswehr auch geschafft.
Ja, da bin ich ja immer wieder dankbar, weil ich finde, das ist irgendwie Humanitarismus und Abrüstung, Friedens schaffen ohne Waffen.
Naja, ich glaube so langsam kann man sich an den Gedanken gewöhnen, dass wir möglicherweise doch eine Bundeswehr in Funktionen...
Aber nicht wenn McKinsey in der Nähe ist.
Nee gut, McKinsey wird das Zufall, das sich verhindern soll. Nur wäre halt glaube ich eher so eine... Könnte man möglicherweise darüber nachdenken, ob man vielleicht doch wieder ein funktionierendes Militär brauchen könnte, eventuell so weitlagetechnisch oder so. Und der McKinsey mal rausschmeißen muss.
Ja, so was ist noch passiert seit der letzten Sendung Israel und Gaza. Da wollen wir eigentlich nicht überreden. Aber eine Sache finde ich doch interessant, nämlich dass der Westen jetzt anfängt, langsam Bibi-Kritik zu äußern. Das war vorher nicht so, oder? Hab ich das nicht gesehen?
Nee, das war schon vorher so, dass irgendwie Bibi-Kritik geäußert wurde. Das war zwischendurch nicht so. Also tatsächlich, also direkt vor dem Hammersangriff gab es schon sehr intensive Bibi-Kritik, auch in den westlichen Medien. Also Netanyahu kam da nicht besonders gut weg. Und direkt dann gab es sogar in den Mainstream-Medien irgendwie tatsächlich so den Hinweis, so das passt ihm aber gerade gut in den Kram. Da war ich ein bisschen erstaunt, dass auch so Guardian und BBC in so einem Spiegel.
Und also der Guardian ist schon länger.
Nee, aber auch Spiegel oder so, ne? Also so irgendwie stramme Mainstream-Medien so. Und dann war es eine Zeit lang weg, weil halt irgendwie andere Themen, also beziehungsweise halt irgendwie sagen wir ja, die die Story eine andere war. Und jetzt wird aber die Kritik an Netanyahu in Israel so laut und so eloquent und auch aus seiner eigenen Regierung, dass die deutschen Mainstream-Medien auch angefangen haben, das halt irgendwie ausführlicher zu berichten. Deshalb das, was passiert ist.
Ich habe ja meine Geschäftsreise in Israel so einen Taxifahrer befragt zu Netanyahu, weil ich mir rausfinden wollte, wie findet eigentlich die Bevölkerung den? Und das fand ich ganz interessant. Der meinte also, pass auf, unsere Geburtenrate ist irgendwie 1,2. Das heißt, die Bevölkerung sinkt bis auf die Palästinenser, die sind irgendwie drei bis vier, also richtig viel mehr. Und die Orthodox-Junen, die haben irgendwie fünf, sieben, acht. Das heißt, wenn du gerne an der Regierung bleiben willst, dann wandelst du dich halt an diese beiden, entweder die einen oder die anderen ran, denn die können sich nicht leiden. Und Netanyahu hat sich halt die unter Orthodoxen gekrallt und hat ihnen alles versprochen, was sie haben wollten. Und meinte, die anderen sind zwar gegen Netanyahu, aber die können halt mit der Geburtenrate nicht mithalten und werden also immer weniger eine Rolle spielen als jetzt schon. Das heißt, der Netanyahu wird jetzt hier bleiben. Hat er mir erklärt. Da würden die wieder in andere Regionen kommen, weil wo soll die mehrheit herkommen? Außer die Palästinenser übernehmen. So und dann meinte der damals schon, naja, da wird es dann wohl demnächst irgendwie einen Krieg geben irgendwo. Okay, also das ist so viel zum Innenbild einer einzelnen Taxifahrerperson aus Israel. Ja, aber das fand ich also eine neue Erfahrung, dass die westlichen Medien anfangen, an den Teilen Jahrhundert zu kritisieren. Und zwar, also es gab es vorher schon, aber das waren dann so taktische, ja, das hätte man jetzt irgendwie geschickter machen können. Aber so Fundamentalkritik.
Nee, nee, doch, doch. Also also die Korruptionsskandal, der war.
Ja gut stimmt, okay, der war tatsächlich.
Der war wirklich sehr breit berichtet. Und eigentlich war der schon abgeschrieben. Also es war halt, das war halt schon relativ, also war das eh nur eine Phase, wo das halt irgendwie nicht so präsent war.
Aber war halt demokratisch legitimiert, neu gewählt worden mit ordentlichen Gerichten und...
Tja, so ist das halt.
Nun ja, na gut. Ja, dann wolltest du noch von deiner Bahnfahrt durch Europa berichten.
Richtig, genau. Ja, ich...
Wo wir gerade bei Gammel da Infrastruktur waren.
Da hab ich noch eine Gelume drüber geschrieben, können wir noch verlinken. Ja, ich hatte irgendwie mehrere Termine quer durch Europa und hatte irgendwie keinen Bock zu fliegen. Und das Budget gab es gerade ja sowohl zeitlich als auch finanziell, was ich da bekommen habe. Dass ich halt mal Bahn fahren konnte. Ich dachte mir, okay, dann fahre ich doch einfach mal irgendwie so zu allem mit der Bahn. Und dann bin ich von Berlin nach München nach Innsbruck. Da war ich an der Uni und dann bin ich von Innsbruck weiter nach Zürich. Und dann bin ich von Zürich nach Paris. Und dann bin ich von Paris nach London und von London nach Amsterdam und von Amsterdam wieder nach Berlin. Und das war eigentlich sehr interessant, weil...
Hast du einmal alle Zuggesellschaften mitgenommen?
Genau, nämlich alle, aber so halt schon einen guten Teil. Der Teil war halt schon ganz spannend. Also tatsächlich irgendwie die Berlin-München-Strecke funktioniert ja ganz okay. Also da war die Verspätung so gering, dass ich den Anschluss doch nach Innsbruck tatsächlich geschafft habe, wenn auch knapp. Und dann halt bis Innsbruck passiert nichts weiter. Und dann Innsbruck nach Zürich, da baute der Zug immer mehr Verspätung auf. Und wie die Ansage sehr diplomatisch formulierte, wegen der Verzögerung eines Ein Zug ist aus dem Ausland.
War das die Österreichische oder die schweizerische Bahn?
Das war die ÖBB, die mich von Innsbruck nach Zürich gebracht hat. Und ja, aber sie meinten natürlich ein deutscher Bahnzug, der halt wie vorher das Glas blockiert hat, der halt irgendwie verspätet war. Und wenn das dann irgendwie echt nett war, dann kam ich halt ins... Also Vorteile von Bahnfahren ist halt grandios, also man sieht halt viel von der Landschaft. Kommt manch auch mit Leuten im Zug ins Gespräch, aber vor allen Dingen kommt man halt mitten in der Stadt an, was halt bedeutet, dass man irgendwie seine Freunde und Bekannte, die in den Städten wohnen, halt einfach mal spontan dazu überreden kann, irgendwie sich zu treffen. So was halt total nett ist. Also hab ich quasi in jeder Stadt gemacht, dass ich da einfach nicht mit Leuten verabredet hab. Wir haben mich dann entweder am Bahnhof geholt, aber wir haben uns dann irgendwo in der Stadt getroffen. Sowas, was du halt nie machen würdest, wenn du dann mit deinem Flugzeug unterwegs bist, weil die Flughäfen halt meistens irgendwo außerhalb sind. Dann brauchst du eine Stunde in die Stadt und so. Und so kommst du halt in der Mitte der Stadt an und es ist irgendwie nett und irgendwie gehst du was essen und läufst noch ein bisschen, machst einen Spaziergang. So und hab ich in Zürich gemacht. Und dann in Paris war auch super nett, weil irgendwie da kommt man halt irgendwie in dem einen Bahnhof an und dann hab ich einen Freund getroffen und wir sind zusammen zu dem anderen Bahnhof gelaufen, quer durch die Innenstadt und unterwegs noch einen Kaffee getrunken und mir haben wir noch ein paar Sachen gezeigt in Paris, so untereinander und dann, was ja fast fertig ist und so, die Renovierung und dann haben sie es geschafft, den Euro City, also Euro Train, also den Zug im Tunnel unten durch, haben sie wirklich das Schlimmste von Flugreisen und Zugreisen in diesem Abzug-Abflug-Terminal kombiniert.
Und das ist nochmal ganz anders als der Hauptbahnhof, wo man ja irgendwie naiv annehmen sollte, wenn du von Paris nach Lotte-Lotte fährst, steigst du am Hauptbahnhof halt oben so, ne, nee.
Nee, nee, das ist halt ein separater Bahnhof. Oder was sagen sie, separater Teil eines Bahnhofs. Und da haben sie dann halt die Sicherheitskontrollen und diese automatischen Pass-Skin-Automaten, die nicht funktionieren. Und irgendwie so, das ist wirklich dann so völlig überfüllte Wartahalle. Also wirklich unsäglich schlecht. Die Züge sind dann eigentlich ganz geil. Essen gab es auf dem Hinweg von den Franzosen. Das war sehr genießbar und ziemlich interessant, weil es halt so unwirklich ist. Du fährst in so einen Tunnel und kommst in einem anderen Land raus, was wirklich doll anders ist, also architektonisch und alles so. Ja, und UK ist halt wirklich schon ganz schön im Eimer so.
Ist dir aufgefallen, wie lang dieser Eurostar ist? Der ist nämlich irgendwie 400 Meter, oder der ist richtig lang. Und der Hintergrund ist, dass sie eine gesetzliche Vorschrift hatten, im Tunnel musst du auf dem Weg, den der Zug im Tunnel steht, einen Ausgang haben. Das heißt, sie haben lieber den Zug sehr lang gemacht, als viele Ausgänge zu bauen. Deswegen ist der so lang, dass er einen normalen Bahnsteig gar nicht halten kann. Deswegen gibt es spezielle Terminals.
Ja, na gut, und der ist auch sehr beliebt. Das war richtig voll.
Ist da gar nicht billig eigentlich die Fahrt?
War nicht teuer. Kann sein, ich hab halt ein bisschen preisorientiert geschoppt. Das war jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr, als du so Hamburg, München bei der Bahn bezahlen würdest. War also nicht teuer. Können wir machen. Also ist okay. Das Ernstliche nervige ist, dass man auch zwei Stunden vorher da sein muss in den ganzen Zirkus. Sicherheits-Bullshit, ja. Ansonsten kann man machen, das suche ich.
Theater, Sicherheitstheater.
Ja, so was halt wirklich beeindruckend war, wie im Eimer halt UK ist. Also ist halt so, wie sehr die sich mit diesem Brexit in den Fuß geschossen haben und inzwischen auch wissen und merken, ist halt schon ganz schön heftig. So und die, also ich war da halt irgendwie beim Vortrag halten und noch irgendwie ein Business Meeting, noch zwei andere Sachen machen. Und da hast du halt irgendwie selbst in Regierungsgebäuden halt so dieses Gefühl, so dass dieses typisch britische Problem, dass du halt die Fassade noch erhalten wirst. Und dann machst du die falsche Tür auf und dann ist es mir wirklich passiert, dass du in einem, in einem, ich sage es mal nicht in welchem, aber du machst halt eine Tür auf und so Mahagoni mit irgendwie so irgendwie Messingknopf und so. Und dann ist dahinter halt so ein, naja, da war halt so ein Treppenhaus und es war halt mit so zwei so quer genagelten Brettern versperrt. Mit so, also, also, was ist das? So Schalungsbretter und dann so ein Schild so, ja, dieses Treppenhaus ist leider irgendwie gerade wegen Reparatur geschlossen und dieses Schild hingen da so, sagen so seit 1978 ungefähr. So, also völlig krass.
Das kenne ich sonst nur aus Hotels, weißt du, wenn irgendwie so du bist in der Lounge mit diesem Hotel.
Also ich war ich war ich war ich war dachte wir okay. Ich hatte ein bisschen Budget, irgendwie Vorträge halten und so irgendwie. Und da, was ich denen überhelf, konnte an Reisekosten und hab mir halt ein Hotel in Kensington gemietet, was halt irgendwie ein halbwegs okay guter Stadtteil von London ist, der auch irgendwie gut gelegen ist und so. Wir sind halt alles so schicke, weiße, dreistöckige Häuser, so fast so ein bisschen willenartig, so und viele davon sind halt Hotels. Und vorne sieht das Hotel auch super aus, halt so total weiß und irgendwie neu gemacht und so. Und dann unten der Empfang, weil es fing ja schon ein bisschen enger zu werden so. Und dann haben sie mir einen Schlüssel gegeben, ich sag ja, zeig ihn mal das Hotel. Und dann ging es dann so durch so eine Tür und dann fing es dann schon an, so ein bisschen rottiger zu werden. Und dann so eine Treppe hoch, die gerade so breit waren wie meine Schultern. Und dann in so eine Ex-Basenkammer, die halt genauso breit war wie das Bett lang, aber wirklich genauso breit. Und dann stand da halt irgendwie so ein Schreibtisch drinnen und dann war so ein Fenster zum Hinterhof. Und der Hinterhof war halt so, sah halt aus wie so eine Charles-Dickens-Novelle. Also so unverputzte Ziegelwände, so wie so völlig krass. Und dann, also der Stuhl unter dem Schreibtisch musste komplett reingeschoben sein, damit die Tür zum Bad aufging gegenüber. Das Fenster war halt so zügig, dass ich in Mütze schlafen musste, um nicht krank zu werden. Und als Bonus war die Wand zum Nachbar-Dings so dünn, dass ich in den Ausscheidungsprozessen des Nachbarn akustisch direkt teilnehmen konnte.
Also mit anderen Worten geräumiges Atelier.
Genau, da hab ich den nächsten Morgen doch irgendwie etwas bitterlich beschwert. Und dann wollten sie mich erst damit abspeisen. Ja, also der Nachbar zieht ja irgendwie gerade aus. Also es wird der nächste Nacht nicht so laut werden. Ich dachte so, nee, ich komm jetzt hier, gib dir aber mein Geld wieder, aber gib mir ein Upgrade. Und dann haben sie mir ein Upgrade gegeben. Interessant fand ich dann halt so, dass irgendwie so durch die, also diese Institutionen in UK, viele von denen werden halt inzwischen zusammengehalten von den Eliten aus den Ex-Kolonien. Da ist halt viele indischstämmige, pakistanischstämmige Leute, die halt irgendwie quasi dann auch so den, die Bewegungen der Regierung machen, also bis hin zum Premierminister halt so. Und die dann halt so in den, in diesen Ruinen des Imperiums rumspucken. Weil was in London halt so auffällt, ist, dass da, also es gibt ja keinen Platz in London. Also du hast halt irgendwie Wohnung, alles super knapp und so. Da hast du diese riesigen Regierungsgebäude, die dafür gebaut wurden, so ein ganzes Empire zu verwalten und die weitgehend leer stehen. Na, da ist niemand. So, da ist eine ganze Flure, die sind abgesperrt, da ist niemand. Die werden auch nicht mehr renoviert, außer die Fenster und die Fassade. Und dann hast du da halt dann so irgendwie so einen Hausmeister, häufig so ein Zick mit Torbahn, der dann da halt noch so den Flur davor irgendwie so wienert. Und aber du siehst halt, irgendwie dahinter geht es halt nicht mehr weiter, ist halt so nicht mehr fertig gerendert, so oder?
Schon heftig. Also interessanterweise, das war jetzt auch wieder ein Taxifahrergespräch, ist das im Land, auf dem Land genauso, in England. Die haben auch überhaupt keine Neubauten, und zwar weil die, die schon eine Wohnung haben, dagegen sind, dass da noch mehr gebaut wird. Obwohl es ihre eigenen Kinder sind, die jetzt keine Wohnung finden. Und das heißt, die wohnen alle bei den Eltern, bis sie 50 sind und übernehmen das Haus, wenn die Eltern sterben, nach dem Motto, ja und wenn du irgendwie zu viele Kinder hast, dann geht es halt nicht. Hättest halt nicht mal Handel und so. Und obwohl eigentlich durchaus noch Platz gewesen wäre, aber die wollen halt nicht so, weil dann wird ja unser Haus weniger wert, wenn jetzt hier noch was anderes gebaut wird. Also das ist komplett selbst verursacht. Ja, in London könnte man ja noch annehmen. Na ja, also so viele Menschen, da gibt es halt irgendwann keinen Platz mehr. Nee, nee, das ist ohne Not selbst zugefügt. Und ja, ich habe noch eine Anekdote aus England. Da bin ich mal nach Cardiff gefahren, das sind Wales, mit einem englischen Zug, weil ich mal sehen wollte, wie da so die Regionalzüge sind. Und dann stand ich also vor dieser Zugtür. Der Zug fährt in den Bahnhof ein und ich finde den Knauf nicht, um die Tür zu öffnen. So, da kein Knopf oder so. Und dann kommt hinter mir so eine Frau, meint so, geh mal weg, schob das Fenster runter, griff durch das Fenster raus und bediente den Knauf außen. Und ich stand da, was passiert hier gerade? Weißt du so? Ja, das ist hier noch ein etwas älterer Zug. Sollte mal ersetzt werden, aber das hat eine deutsche Gesellschaft gekauft und die investiert ja nicht. So, und ich stand da so, was passiert hier gerade? Also super, super geil. So richtig schiebe Fenster auch ohne Automatismus, sondern einfach so fasst du halt an und die Reibung zieht es nach oben und unten. Also echt krass. Infrastruktur vergammelt, aber da sind wir auch dabei. Wobei übrigens die Bahn in Deutschland, muss ich dann doch mal eine Lanze brechen, habe ich in letzter Zeit nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Also in Berlin, die S-Bahn ist frisch. Nicht überall, glaube ich, aber so die Linien, die ich fahre, die Ringbahn, da sind super moderne Züge. Und die Regionalzüge sind auch sehr neu. Und der Effekt ist, wenn du im Zug sitzt, dass das Fahrgeräusch sehr gering ist. Da müsst ihr mal auf achten, wenn ihr mal mit der Bahn unterwegs seid. Neue Züge erkennt man daran, dass die keinen Geräusch machen. Früher kannte man noch so Ratter, Ratter, Quietsch, Quietsch. So neue Züge sind wirklich so leise, dass man eigentlich nicht merkt, dass man fährt. Ja, also kommt natürlich auch auf die Strecke an und so. Und wie der Fahrer gerade drauf ist. Aber das ist richtig gut geworden im Vergleich. So die Züge, die es gibt, die Züge, also von dem, von der Möblierung sind die, sind die Regionalzüge eine Katastrophe, weil das die Landesregierung festlegt und nicht die Bahngesellschaft. Auch von dem, auch der, der wie, wie viele Züge fahren und wie lang die sind, legt alles die Landesregierung fest. Das heißt, die Leute, die uns sozusagen das Deutschlandticket gegeben haben, damit wir mehr Regionalbahnen fahren, werden auch die gewesen, die dann halt für mehr Regionalzüge hätten sorgen müssen. Haben es aber nicht gemacht. Also da ist es falsch, an der Stelle auf die Bahn zu kloppen. Das ist tatsächlich die Landesregierung. Aber also ich fahre immer noch begeistert mit dem Deutschlandticket rum und gucke mir irgendwelche Sachen an, wo ich sonst nicht vorbeigekommen wäre. Letztes Wochenende war ich in Jüterbock. Das ist so ein im Süden Berlins eine Kleinstadt. Und ich kannte die vorher nur, weil ich mal recherchiert habe, wenn man hier mal Braunkohletagebaugebiete besuchen will. Naja, die haben so Bagger, die irgendwie haushoch sind. Das ist schon so aus Technik-Nerd-Sicht durchaus mal ein interessantes Ziel. Und dann hatte ich das mal ausgesucht und da stand halt, okay, du musst erst nach Jüterbock fahren. Und dann nimmst du dein Auto hier und da. Und ich hab halt kein Auto mehr. Dann hat sich das halt geerdet. Aber Jüterbock ist dann auch nie was geworden. Und da sind wir jetzt halt mal hingefahren, einfach am Wochenende so spontan, weil da, wo wir eigentlich hinwollten, das hat sich irgendwie nicht ergeben. Und zufällig war an genau dem Wochenende dann da ein Stadtfest wegen 850 Jahre irgendwie Jüterbock-Stadtrechte. So völlig unerwartet. Und da gab es dann so einen Marsch, haben sie da so eine Route festgelegt, wo dann irgendwie Eventstände waren, wo man dann irgendwie Sachen erzählte. Richtig schön, ja? Also Berliner, wenn ihr ein Ziel sucht, geht mal nach Jüterbock, ist nett. Da wohnen so 10.000 Leute, ist relativ klein, aber haben eine alte Stadtmauertürme.
Ja, ich war noch in Blutschle Park.
Bist du auch mit der Bahn hin?
Ich bin mit der Bahn hingefahren. Ja, ich fahre in England nicht Auto, weil ich nicht muss.
Nee, aber es gibt auch Coach. Also es gibt so ein Bussystem in England, was deutlich also inzwischen gibt es ja auch viele so Langstreckenbusse, aber in England ist mir das zum ersten Mal begegnet.
Ich finde Busfahren schwierig.
Ja, also heute hätte ich da glaube ich auch Probleme, weil einfach zu viele verunfallt sind und weil du denkst irgendwie der Fahrer wird wahrscheinlich nicht ausgeschlafen sein und so. Und vielleicht ist der Bus auch nicht so sauber, aber als ich das mal gemacht habe, da musste ich Richtung Cambridge und da konnte man von dem Flughafen in London, der ist ja nicht in London, der ist ja auch aus einem der Flughäfen. Genau, einer der Flughäfen bei London. Von da aus gab es dann halt einen Codeservice und der war richtig schön. Das war so ein Bus, der fuhr da halt irgendwie gemächlich übers Land. Schöne Aussicht, der hat auch nicht irgendwie einfach nur Autobahn genommen und da gab es Wi-Fi in dem Bus, was ja völlig unerhört war damals. Also ich kann nicht schlechtes sagen über den Bus-Service in England. Das war gut.
Ja, ich mag Busfahren eigentlich nicht, weil ich also wenn ich einen Zug haben kann...
Ich mach das auch fast nie, aber das war eine der Ausnahmen.
Wenn ich einen Zug haben kann, nämlich einen Zug. Also der Zug war, naja, hat jetzt nicht schlimmer als ein deutscher AE. Der Bahnhof in Bletchley Park war krass runtergekommen.
Konnte man denn deinen Zug von innen aufmachen?
Die Türen ging automatisch auf so geil. Das Museum in Bletchley Park, also Bletchley Park ist halt irgendwie da, wo die Briten halt die Enigma geknackt haben. Also das ist quasi so ein gewisser Weihfahrtsort, wenn man mit Kryptographie zu tun hat.
Und auch National Pride für England. Eine der größten Erwunsch- haften, die sie auf die Fahne schreiben können.
Ja, da schreib ich noch ein bisschen ausführlicher zu. Vielleicht schaff ich's sogar noch am Wochenende. Das Museum da ist halt irgendwie eigentlich ganz interessant aus zwei Gründen. Also zum einen, weil das Museum an sich ist halt wirklich unnäcklich disnifiziert. Also es ist halt wirklich so ein Museum, wo du denkst, okay, jetzt habt ihr mal so ein Museum, wo wirklich mal so jeden Technik-Nerd, der irgendwie so auch nur in 100 Kilometer umkreist ist, der wird da vorbeifahren. Was haben sie da aber gemacht? Sie haben es komplett irgendwie so disnifiziert. Also halt so auf so ein Niveau runtergezogen, wo du denkst, könnte doch in jedem anderen Ort machen, aber warum hier? Also es ist dann so ganze Baracken, die dann so mit so subjektiven Experiences von dieser oder jenen Subgruppe, die mal da war, irgendwie wie deren Zeit in Bletchley Park so war.
Okay, das heißt überhaupt nichts über Krypto?
Es gibt so am Rande auch noch so ein bisschen was über Krypto, aber halt mehr so am Rande. Und sie haben halt keine funktionsfähigen Nachbauten da von den Maschinen. Sie haben halt irgendwie das System, wie irgendwie die Sachen dekodiert und dechiffriert wurden, halt so nur sehr ansatzweise erläutert. Und dann halt irgendwie gibt es halt dann so zwei, drei Exponate, die interessant sind. Und dann enden die aber irgendwie so in so einem, das Ganze ist halt total für Kinder irgendwie aufbereitet und so.
Haben sie denn eine Enigma wenigstens oder auch nicht?
Da stehen so zwei, drei Enigmas rum und so.
Na immerhin.
Und dann war ich halt irgendwie so, dann ist halt alles aber eher so ein Schulklassenmuseum. Aber ein schlechtes Schulklassenmuseum. Und dann hab ich dann irgendwann mal eine Verzweiflung der einen von den rumstehenden Leute gefragt, die da halt mal irgendwie die Sicherheit oder Besucherservice machten. Und da hab ich mich ja schon ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil irgendwie keine Hardware und da geht ziemlich wenig zur Krypto und so. Und wieso denn und so? Und dann meinte er, ah, you're one of those. Und dann meinte er, wir haben schon auf sie gewartet. Und meinte er, pass auf. Und dann gehste raus aus dem Museum. Und dann biegste links ab. Und dann gehste über den Parkplatz. Und dann läufste geradeaus. Keep walking. Bis du nicht mehr weiterlaufen kannst. Und dann siehst du so eine große, so eine Baracke, die außerhalb des Museums Geländes so eine Serie von so grauen, ein bisschen runtergeranzten Baracken. Dann wirst du da so ein kleines Schild sehen, auf dem steht National Museum of Computing. Da willst du hingehen.
Okay, der Mann sieht aus, die Scheune hinter der Scheune ist so ein Kellereingang. Und dann gehst du dann rein, aber nur am Samstag um drei.
Genau. Dann hab ich das natürlich gemacht. Und das war die beste Entscheidung von dieses Tages. Weil das National Museum of Computing ist halt ein von...
Ein Fernbetrieb.
Freiwilligen am Leben gehaltenes, ich glaube viele von diesen Freiwilligen sind aktuelle oder ehemalige Mitarbeiter vom GCHQ. Museum, das als Aufgabe sich gesetzt hat, also als Mission, jeden jemals in UK gebauten Computer in funktionsfähig dazu haben, infunktionsfähig. Die haben einen Colossus nachgebaut in voll funktionsfähig. Die haben eine voll funktionsfähige Bombe nachgebaut, also den elektromechanischen Computer. Die haben eine funktionsfähige originale Witch.
Ich schreib dir mal Sachen, von denen du noch nie gehört hast.
Genau, also ich schreib dir mal Zeug in meiner Kolumne drüber mit Bildern. Ich hab unglaublich viele Bilder und ich hab den ganzen Rest des Tages da verbracht. Die mussten mich da am Ende so höflich bitten zu gehen, so weil...
Security!
Die waren auch super nett. Also wenn ihr nicht viel Zeit habt, dann spart euch dieses Bletchley Park Disney Museum, geht direkt zum National Museum of Computing. Da ist der Hammer. Also wirklich so, die Leute, die da sind, sind halt auch die Nerds, die das Zeug bauen und am Laufen halten und so. Also wirklich toll. Also wirklich so ein richtig tolles Nordmuseum. Das war ein sehr guter Teil. Dann war ich noch im Imperial War Museum. Was ein tolles.
Das sind eher so Bomben und Hauwitzer oder was?
Na, das ist halt ein Museum aller wesentlichen Kriege, in die das United Kingdom mal verwickelt war, bis in die jüngere Zeit.
Das ist immer der lange Lüste, oder?
Ein großes Museum. Und das Museum ist nur wirklich ein winziger Teil, also ein winziger Teil der Sammlung. Das ist ein ganzer Cityblock quasi. Da hinten noch die ganzen Hallen und dann haben sie noch diverse Außengelände und so. Das ist quasi nur sehr aufbereiteter Teil des Zentrums. Was ich daran interessant finde, ist, dass sie, dass sie so eine Mischung aus so diesem zu erwartenden imperialen Patriotismus und einer relativ differenzierten Sicht auf den jeweiligen Konflikt haben. Das fand ich sehr ungewöhnlich. Also sie haben halt irgendwie schon so ja, und unsere Helden und so. Aber dann halt aber eben auch so ein ja und irgendwie hier. Und dieser Konflikt war scheiße deswegen. Und wir fingen an deswegen. Und hier hatte die Diplomatie versagt. Und hier haben wir halt irgendwie irgendwie das Ende dieses Krieges war irgendwie super ungerecht, weil und so und so viele Zivilisten sind umgekommen. Und so als erstaunlich interessante Mischung. Also war wie so war doch durchaus. Ich musste ein bisschen Speedrun machen, weil ich weil er einen Termin ein bisschen länger dauerte, irgendwie nur eineinhalb Stunden hatten, und bin da wirklich so auf Tempo dadurch.
Auch so moderne Konflikte, Falklands und so?
Mhm, Falklands und Neuerland und so und auch auch die. Okay, also für ein britisches Museum, okay gut behandelt. Lohnt tatsächlich, also es ist halt irgendwie ein interessantes Museum auf jeden Fall so und das ist halt wiederum auch einer der positiven Aspekte, muss man sagen von London, ist, dass es halt unglaublich viele Museen gibt und sehr viele von den Kosten sind kostenlos. Sie entweder von einer Charity betrieben werden oder von Dation oder halt vom Staat und deswegen wenig Kosten. Es gibt aber auch unglaublich viele extrem teure Touristen-Abzock-Attraktionen, gerade so im Zentrum so um.
Gut, das British Museum hat jetzt auch keine Kosten für die Beschaffung der Artefakte. Immer auf der Strand. Sorry, da musste ich rauf, jetzt kann ich auf der Strand vorbeilaufen.
Natürlich, ja. Na gut, es gibt halt auch jede Menge so, keine Ahnung, so Westminster Abbey kostet halt irgendwie keine 20 Pfund oder so. Da hat die mir auch so, nee, lasst mal, kann ich irgendwie im Interen klicken. So, das ist halt so sehr uneinheitlich. Ja, aber ansonsten.
Ja, ich war auch mal im British Museum und wollte den Rosetta-Stone sehen. Und das ging einfach gar nicht. Da war so eine fette Mensch und traube drum, da konnte ich nicht mal so, nicht mal so irgendwie Handy hochhalten, so hoch du kannst. Und von oben runter nicht mal da hast du irgendwas erkennen können.
Die Mainstream-Museen sind einfach überfüllt. Aber die Special-Interest-Sachen sind sehr, sehr lohnt. Also wie gesagt, schon wieder sind wir auf Computing. Dringend Empfehlung. Imperial War Museum, wenn man sich dafür so Sachen interessiert, auch sehr, sehr gut kann man machen. Genau, und auf der Rückfahrt dann ist dann sozusagen, den Bogen noch zu Ende zu machen, bin ich dann halt irgendwann wieder nach Amsterdam, also über Amsterdam zurück nach Berlin. Auch wieder Amsterdam, sehr nett, irgendwie noch ein bisschen Zeit gehabt. Irgendwie kommt er auch mit in einer Stadt an. Und dann stieg ich in den Zug nach Berlin und dann kam ich nur bis Hengelo, was irgendwie eine...
Nah genug.
Ziemlich klein.
Aus holländischer Sicht so gut wie in Deutschland.
Genau, also eine ziemlich kleine Stadt an der Grenze. Und da gab es dann einen Oberleitungsschaden im Raum Hannover und dann fuhr halt einfach mal genau nichts mehr nach Wissen. Und dann war so die Anzeige, ja und so. Und dieser Zug endet jetzt hier, weil irgendwie wir haben hier irgendwie wegen eines Problems, haben sie erst mal gesagt. Und danach in der Deutschen Bahn geklickt, da stand dann irgendwas von Oberleitungsschaden, Raum Hannover und irgendwie. Und dann meinten die so dann, ja, den Schiff mal fahrt sowas wissen, meinte er fährt heute nichts mehr so. Und dann war so die Anzeige so, ja. Und die Deutsche Bahn wird Ersatzbus auf dem Bahnhof Vorplatz. Also als ich das Wort Ersatzbus und Deutsche Bahn im selben Satz hörte, hatte ich sofort mein Telefon draußen, hab mir erst mal in dem einzigen Hotel im Ort ein Zimmer geklickt, weil ich wusste, das wird heute nichts mehr so.
Aber die hätten dich dann bis Berlin gefahren oder was?
Nein, irgendwo über die Grenze und dann viel Glück.
Ja geil.
Also nach, keine Ahnung, wo, Wuppertal oder so. Keine Ahnung, was da da gings.
Also ich muss dir sagen, mein Blick auf sowas hat sich geändert, seit ich mit dem Deutschland-Ticket unterwegs bin, weil ich jetzt einfach auch auf Verdacht einfach mal in irgendwelche Städte gefahren bin und eigentlich jedes Mal positiv überrascht war. Also ich kann wirklich keine Einzige nennen, wo ich es rückblickend sagen würde, da wäre ich jetzt nicht hinfahren sollen. Und ich bin so ignoranter Wessi, würde ich mal sagen. Das heißt, das gesamte Gebiet Brandenburg und so kenne ich von der Karte. Aber so die Historie der Städte da ist mir völlig oder weitgehend unbekannt. Das heißt, du findest eigentlich überall was und wenn die Bahn mich irgendwo strandet, dann wäre mein erster Instinkt irgendwie, nein, dann gucke ich mich hier halt um.
Habe ich in Hengelo probiert.
Gut, also Hengelo gibt es jetzt.
Hengelos ist im Zweiten Weltkrieg so gründlich kaputt gemacht worden. Und danach haben sie den Rest noch abgerissen. Da war wirklich nicht so viel zu entdecken.
Aber irgendeine Sehenswürdigkeit gab es doch, erinnere ich mich.
Die hat er aber zu. Na super.
Nee, ich sage das jetzt, weil du Wuppertal sagst. Da gibt es einfach.
Wuppertal ist okay. Ich meine, Wuppertal kann man... Aber problematisch sind halt so die D-Städte im Westen, halt so Duisburg, Dortmund, Düsseldorf und so. Die finde ich so ein bisschen schwierig, aber...
Ach, da gibt es auch schöne Sachen zu sehen.
Ja, das stimmt. Man sollte da nicht so viele vor Ort haben.
Nee, aber der Punkt ist vor allem, man muss, glaube ich, wegkommen von diesem, wir planen das jetzt so. Die Reisen, wo ich entweder den Plan über den Haufen werfen musste oder wo ich einfach gar keinen hatte und dann einfach mir Sachen angeguckt habe, die waren rückblickend besser als die.
Wenn ich die Zeit habe, mache ich das ja genauso. Also wenn ich die Zeit habe, dann so, ich wollte halt nur irgendwann mal wieder nach Berlin.
Naja, ich verstehe das ja. Aber in solchen Fällen ist es, glaube ich, besser, wenn man sich dann einfach ein, zwei Tage vor Ort nimmt und sich umguckt.
Ich meine, ich mach, also früher bin ich halt mit der Deutschen Bahn auch selber hin und zurück in München gefahren oder so was.
Ja, das traue ich mir gar nicht.
Kann man nicht mehr machen. So muss man reisen als Reisenplan. Zusammenfassend kann ich sagen, es war außerhalb des Gebiets der Deutschen Bahn bis auf die eine Verspätung irgendwie nach Zürich. Alles okay. Also selbst in England gab es keine signifikante Verspätung. Die Züge funktionierten und waren sauber. Es war alles überhaupt kein Problem. Und wenn man sich auf diese Art des Reisens einlässt und sagt, okay, das Coole ist, ich kann meine Freunde in den Städten durch die Reise treffen oder mir noch ein Museum angucken oder was auch immer, ist es auf jeden Fall eine sehr coole Art zu reisen und ich werde es auf jeden Fall auch wieder machen. Man muss sagen, es dauert sehr, sehr lange. Und das hat im Vergleich zu fliegen halt schon ziemlich langsam und vor allem teurer.
Was ich halt hier probieren kann.
Und viel, viel teurer. Also ich bin gerade, ich wollte auch eine Reise machen, wollte fliegen, wollte mit Zug fahren und hab festgestellt, der einzige Weg ist irgendwie mit dem Nachtzug. Die Nachtzüge der österreichischen Bundesbahn sind Monate hinaus ausgebucht und sind viermal so teuer wie fliegen auf derselben Strecke. Und dann war auch nicht genug Zeit. Also hätte einfach nicht die 18 Stunden Zugfahrt wäre einfach nicht drin gewesen, wo es auch zweieinhalb Stunden Flug hätte sein können.
Da muss man vielleicht noch dazu erklären, dass die Nachtzüge der österreichischen Bundesbahn eigentlich Nachtzüge der deutschen Bahn waren, die die verkauft haben, die Vollidioten zum Teil. Ja gut, die haben auch eigene gehabt. Aber das alte IC-Zugmaterial, was die jetzt irgendwie teuer restauriert und umgebaut haben, das kam ursprünglich zum Großteil von der deutschen Bahn.
Zum Glück, muss man eigentlich sagen, hat die ÖBB es getan. Deswegen gibt es halt noch ein Nachtzugsystem in Europa.
Ich finde das auch super geil. Aber du musst halt reserviert haben.
Ewig vorher. Ewig vorher.
Und es ist halt richtig teuer.
Ja, es ist richtig teuer und die haben den Preis auch gerade wieder erhöht.
Auf der anderen Seite kommst du halt morgens frisch erholt an. Das ist schon geil.
Hängt davon ab, mit welchem Material du fährst. In einigen von diesen Zügen war ich tatsächlich ziemlich krank, weil die Klimaanlage zieht. Dann nimmt man immer besser eine Rolle Gafferband mit, um die Schlitze abzukleben.
Ja, also ich bin in meinem Leben, ich glaube, drei Mal oder so Nachzug gefahren. Und wenn du dann Schlafwagen hast, ist das eine total geile Erfahrung.
Genau, also wenn der Wagen okay ist.
Du darfst halt keinen Liegewagen haben, das ist so der Anfängerfehler. Dann hast du nämlich einen Sitz und da sagen sie, den kannst du ja nach hinten rollen, so nach hinten, das vergisst das. Also das gibt richtige Betten und da bist du halt nicht allein im Apartment, außer du kaufst das ganze Apartment. Aber so für eine Familientour ist das richtig geil. Und vor allem war es früher so, dass man sein Auto mitnehmen konnte. Es gab dieses Konzept Autoreise zu. Das heißt, du hast als Familie sozusagen im Zug geschlafen und kamst dann morgens in Innsbruck an. Das habe ich mal gemacht und fuhrst dann hinten dein Auto runter und konntest einfach mit dem Auto dann in die Alpen fahren. Das ist scheiße teuer gewesen, aber es war halt der richtige Anfang für einen Urlaub, weil du kommst halt nicht müde an, sondern morgens frisch ausgeschlafen voller Tatendrank. Na gut, ich glaube, das war inhaltlich, was wir uns vorgenommen hatten. Ab jetzt wird es wieder gut. Das Wetter wird immer besser. Nein, nicht eins, wir vergessen das Wetter. Aber am Ende müssen wir immer so ein bisschen Hoffnung machen.
Wieso? Und ich finde, dass das Wetter besser wird, ist schon mal ein guter Anfang für Hoffnung. Ja, da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher.
Wir haben jetzt schon knapp 30 Grad gehabt im April.
Ja, das Wetter wird besser, sag ich doch.
Ja, das heißt, wir werden im Juni irgendwie regelmäßig über 30 haben.
Guck, ich meine, wir können auch einfach häufiger hier sein, an diesem 16,5 Grad Keller.
Okay, also nächste Sendung versprichst du gerade.
Genau, wenn Fefe zu warm ist, machen wir eine Sendung.
Alles klar.
Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Fahrt mehr Baden.
Genau, fahrt mehr Baden.
Übrigens eine Sache noch. Ich bin jetzt dazu übergegangen, teilweise tatsächlich Regionalbusse zu nehmen, also so VBB-Linienbusse, nicht irgendwie Regional-Langstrecke.
Okay.
Weil du da eben dann die einsame Dorfstraße mitkriegst. Also das ist teilweise richtig deutschisch und das dauert natürlich ewig. Aber es gibt, habe ich jetzt gerade erst rausgefunden, es gibt auch so eine Art Pseudo-Regionalbus. Den habe ich gesehen von Bad Belzig, war das glaube ich, nach Wittenberg. Das ist schon eine etwas längere Strecke. Und der ist immer noch im Deutschland-Ticket drin.
Ah, okay.
So und habe ich jetzt auch mal eine Liste gemacht, den werde ich mal nehmen. Wittenberg kann ich auch empfehlen, richtig schön. Reformation in Jüterbock steht übrigens auch, er hat auch eine wichtige Rolle gespielt in der Reformation, weil da in der Kirche der Tetzel war, der Gegenspieler sozusagen.
Und da steht die Tetzeltruhe. Das ist so eine große Truhe, wo der halt die Kohle gesammelt hat, die die Leute für die Ablassbriefe gezahlt haben. So als Ausklang kann ich vielleicht noch eine Story erzählen, die an der Truhe, an so einem Schild steht. Ja, also eines Tages kommt ein Ritter zu Tetzel und möchte gerne einen Ablassbrief kaufen für eine Sünde, die er noch nicht begangen hat. Und Tetzel so, ja, ne, so ist das aber nicht gedacht, weil die katholische Kirche wollte verkünden, dass alle voller Sünde sind und Ablass kaufen müssen, ob sie was gemacht haben oder nicht. Und der Ritter meinte so, ne, ne, das kommt noch. Und Tetzel wollte nicht, bis er den Goldberg sah, den der Ritter also zahlen wollte für den Ablass, meinte er, gut. Okay. So, dann will er die Truhe mit der Kohle nach Magdeburg zum Bischof bringen und wird auf dem Weg überfallen, von dem Ritter. Das fand ich eine schöne Hacker-Geschichte. Er hat irgendwie die Regeln gesehen und sich gesagt, oh, das kann man hacken. In diesem Sinne, fahrt mehr rum, guckt euch irgendwie Dorfkirchen an. Berlin selbst ist ja nicht so alt. Wir haben hier 750 Jahre Feier gehabt von einer Weile.
Das ist schon noch eine Weile her.
Ja, aber so Größenordnung. Und Jüterbock ist irgendwie 850 Jahre Stadtrecht. Und ist aber, erste urkundliche Erwähnung, ist irgendwie um 1009 oder so. Also ist schon noch älter. Das sind Juwelen einfach, die man erst sieht, wenn man reinfährt.
Also was ich auch immer sehr interessant finde, ist, welche von diesen kleinen Städten, die so manchmal dem Besuch lohnen, Hansestädte sind. Ja, weil die Hanse war ja mitnichten nur halt irgendwie so die Ostsee und Nordsee Städte, sondern die Hanse war ja eine Handelsorganisation und die dann halt irgendwie auch sehr, sehr viel weiter reinging. Und also was mich immer sehr interessiert bei solchen kleineren Städten ist dann halt, wovon haben die eigentlich früher gelebt? Man kann eigentlich immer so an der Größe der Kirchen sehen, wie wichtig die waren. Wie wichtig und wie, also vor allen Dingen, wie viel Geld die Stadt früher hatte. Also die haben halt mit ihren Kirchen geprotzt und mit ihren Rathäusern.
Und die Kirche in Jüterbock ist besonders, weil die lauter so sakrale Artefakte ausgestellt haben, so alte Altäre, Marinenfiguren und so richtig alt. Ja, also geht da mal hin, wenn ihr euch für so was interessiert. Ansonsten Tipp Magdeburg. Magdeburg ist auch ein großes Zentrum gewesen und das Magdeburger Recht könnt ihr vorher mal googeln oder ihr lest halt vor Ort. Ja, also ich empfinde das als so eine Bereicherung, was ich dank des Deutschlandtickets einfach gesehen habe an Sachen. Und vor allem auch wenn ihr mal irgendwo hinfahrt und die haben irgendwie so ein Heimat- oder Stadtmuseum, geht da mal hin.
Man lernt immer was dabei.
Man lernt was und man kriegt auch eine ganz neue, ganz neues Heimatgefühl, weißt du so? Weil man einfach wie, also ich als Westberliner war immer so, das war so wie so eine Insel, weil das war halt im Meer der DDR, wo ich nicht hin konnte. Oder ich hätte wahrscheinlich schon irgendwie theoretisch, aber praktisch nicht. Und erst jetzt durch dieses Rumfahren krieg ich langsam das Gefühl, eingebettet zu sein in so einer Art irgendwie Heimat, Land, nicht nur so die Stadt, sondern...
Okay, interessant.
Ja, also ich, ist wirklich eine Bereicherung, kann das nur empfehlen.
Na gut, in diesem Sinne...
Viel Spaß.
Viel Spaß, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und...
Bis zum nächsten Mal.